. Star Drink Iso-Light Grapefruit-Zitronengeschmack mit Vitaminendrink aus dem Jahre 2016, aus dem hier örtlichen Netto. Also du musst erst mal einen Schluck nehmen. Wann wurde das produziert? Meinst du wirklich, das wurde 2016 produziert? Vielleicht wurden die auch alle schon 2013 produziert, die liegen schon seit Jahren rum. Ich finde auch, je professioneller man isst und trinkt, desto ekliger wird's auch eigentlich, weil dann fangen die ja an, so in dem Mund quasi mit der Zunge so sehr viel zu arbeiten, wie so Zungenübungen. Seinen Gaumen rüber zu ziehen. Aber das schmeckt ganz gut, du! Aber das Gurgeln ist ein Mythos, oder? Dass man bei einer Weinverkostung gurgelt, das ist Quatsch. Gab es da schon mal einen Sketch? Ich glaube, da gab es mehr als Sketch. Wo man extrem übertrieben Dinge macht, auch einen Handstand oder so, wo man sich schüttelt, den ganzen Kopf schüttelt. Das ist nicht schlecht, ich kenne nur Bulli-Parade, weil die das Spucken das dann ja alles aus in so einen Eimer und dass dieser Eimer dann direkt zum Ballermann als Sangria geliefert wird. Das ist ein Sketch aus der Bulli-Parade, die soll jetzt wieder aufgelegt werden.
Man darf jetzt mal sein. Als Film, ne?
Der Bulli-Parade-Film, weil ich
irgendwie das Kontraproduktivste
der Welt finde. Ein Format,
was da gut funktioniert hat als Serie.
Ja, vor allem als kleine Sketch-Comedy,
als kleine Titbits.
Funktioniert nicht. Falls ihr euch fragen, wer euch
hier diese wohligen Worte
in die Ohren säuselt.
Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich
wie immer wieder und wieder
Vielen Dank. Funktioniert nicht. Falls ihr euch fragen, wer euch hier diese wohligen Worte in die Ohren säuselt, mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich wie immer wieder und wieder und wieder und immer wieder und immer wieder und immer wieder. Er ist wieder da und nächste Folge ist er wahrscheinlich auch da und in zehn Folgen wird er vielleicht auch noch da sein. Es ist er, Stefan Dieter. Und gegenüber von mir, gegenüber von mir, er strahlt mich an, Lebensfreude schwappt mir entgegen quasi, er läuft über vor, weiß ich nicht, Esprit, würde ich mal sagen. Och, das ist ja nettes Wort, danke schön. Esprit, er hat wieder sein, woran ihr kennt, sein Signature Rocket Beans verwaschenes Shirt an. Ist es eigentlich, ist es von Natur aus verwaschen oder hast du es aufgetragen? Nee, ich habe es extra nochmal verwaschen. Ich habe es extra ein paar Mal gewaschen, damit es so aussieht. Stonewashed Rocket Beans Shirt. Ging aber von mir, selbst Florentin will. Stefan, du riechst gut. Ist mir heute direkt aufgefallen, dass ich reinkomme. Du riechst gut, du hast diesen Geruch von einem selbstbewussten schwarzen Mann. Wirklich, der an einem Sommertag einfach mal rausgeht. Du hast mich gerade mit einer rassistischen Beleidigung beleidigt, die nicht immer gegen mich ging. Die Rassismus ging nicht mal gegen mich, nur die Beleidigung. Aber kennst du diese Schwarzen, die ihre Hemden immer ganz bis nach oben zugeknöpft haben und die dann so ganz aufrecht durch die Gegend laufen? Nur aus Filmen tatsächlich. Ja, kenne ich auch nur so aus, wenn man sie so sieht, aus New York oder sowas. Aber habe ich heute tatsächlich in Köln gesehen und der roch genau so wie du. Der ist an mir vorbeigelaufen, hatte so einen Kinderwagen vor sich, auch mit einem kleinen roten Kind tatsächlich drin, dachte ich mir ein bisschen, okay, interessante Kombination, aber tatsächlich an mir vorbeigefahren. Aber schwarz und orange könnte rot ergeben. Nee, schwarz und gelb eigentlich? Nee, das ergibt, glaube ich, so ein Ocker. Hat das einfach mal jemand festgelegt, wie die Farben sind oder sind die natürlich? Ich glaube, die sind relativ natürlich. Ja? Klar. Hat man ja früher, hat man das getestet, da gab es diese Farbpaletten, die Maler haben, diese Klischee, diese eierwörmigen Paletten quasi, wo ein Daumenloch drin ist und da haben die das, glaube ich, getestet. Wer war der Erste, der die Idee hatte, dass man die nicht einfach so greift, sondern so ein Loch macht zum Daumen? Ur-Gross-Vater. Ur-Gross-Vater. Ach, Ur-Gross-Vater. Der wurde sehr alt, deswegen nur mein Ur-Gross-Vater, das würde man sagen. Ich übrigens, um jetzt von dieser peinlichen Einbahnstrasse eines Gags wegzukommen, ich habe ein Parfum tatsächlich, trage ich. Das ist auch nicht so verbreitet mittlerweile mehr. Bei uns war es damals sehr verbreitet, aber für dich war das ein What? Nee, also in der Schule damals gab es immer nur einen, der Parfum getragen hat, halt so der coole Typ. Der Lehrer. Der Lehrer. Komm, riech mir mal ein Parfum, ein bisschen näher. Ja, und ansonsten eigentlich nicht, also natürlich zu besonderen Anlässen, klar, wenn man mal an einem Sonntagabend MacDrive einfach mal sich schön ins Auto setzen, klar, da sprühe ich mal ein bisschen wie... Oder zweite Stunde Bio bei Frau Dings hier, Bums, wie sie noch? Wo ich ein Salzreferat halten musste, das war eine gute Zeit, ein Salzreferat, das habe ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, ich habe ein Salzreferat gehalten und es gab zwei Teile, musste ich in Chemie ein Salzreferat halten, über Salz, das war die klassische Situation, ein Referat halten, damit man nicht durchfällt. Moment, du hast gerade gesagt, du hast ein Salzreferat über Salz gehalten. Jetzt habe ich folgende Frage in meinem Kopf, was ist ein Salzreferat, wenn es nicht zwangsläufig um Salz geht? So eine Art Technik irgendwie, so man tröpfelt das Wissen wie Salz über die Schüler oder was ist ein Salzreferat? Es ist das Salzstreueprinzip im Grunde. Also du wendest enorme Kraft auf und am Ende vielleicht zu vier, fünf Streusel Salz auf dem Tisch haben. Oder zu viel, viel zu viel, dass du sie überfordernst. Oder viel zu viel. Versalzen, sagt man dann auch. Der Schüler ist versalzen. Ja, oder das Salz in der Suppe ist dann wieder positiv. Auf jeden Fall war es ein Chemie-Referat und es gab zwei Teile. Mein Kollege hat alles Chemische gemacht zum Thema Salz und ich hatte den Rest. So er hat dann so erklärt, ja die Strukturformeln und hier diese ganze Formel an die Wand gemalt, Elektronen und hier und da und dann so und jetzt was zur Anwendung, erzählt euch noch der Florentin. Ja, es gibt Pommes und es gibt Potato Wedges und es gibt Curly Pommes und es gibt Kartoffelbrei. Man kann noch auf auf Steaks Salz machen. Aber Vorsicht, es ist nicht dasselbe wie Zucker, auch wenn es so ähnlich aussieht. Und Zucker kann man in Tee, Gummibären, es gibt verschiedene Tees, Grün, Weissen, Grün. Und ihr habt tatsächlich eins zu eins die Wikipedia-Seite von Salz einfach runtergeratet. Wichtig ist Salz auch in der Gerberkunst, also im Gerberhandwerk, also in der Lederverarbeitung. Synonym, synonym, einfach mal mehr, wir brauchen mehr Synonyme. Aber ich finde auch geil, wie einfach Wikipedia die Referatlandschaft, den Referatstandort,, er komplett verändert hat und vereinfacht hat einfach.
Referate waren früher halt, glaube ich, da hat man dann Pappen vorbereitet, so grosse als das Internet und PowerPoint und nicht gar,
da hat man dann grosse so auf Pappmachee Dinge gebaut noch, so Modelle gebaut.
Glaubst du, Leute hatten vor PowerPoint eine Pappe, die sich aufgehalten haben? Ja, doch, in amerikanischen Filmen machen die auch immer noch so grosse Pappen.
Ja, aber nur bei so liebesbeweisen, so Anträgen, wenn du unter dem Fenster deines Schwarm stehst, dann hältst du den Papen, aber nicht beim Referat. Was für eine Pappe, was soll denn da draufstehen? Keine Ahnung, ich liebe dich oder sowas? Ich liebe dich so sehr, ich habe eine Pappe für dich gemacht, bemalt. Ja, im Regen. Kennst du nicht den Film? Der Typ aus Walking Dead. Ja, oder nein, sag mir gar nichts. Deine Romcom Basics müssen wir ein bisschen aufgefrischt werden, glaube ich. Ja, aber jedenfalls, glaube ich, hat das dann auch immer alles verändert, so ein Referat. Ja, aber eigentlich hat es Referate jetzt erst interessant gemacht, weil das Wissen selbst überhaupt keine Herausforderung mehr ist. Man muss sich jetzt nur noch was überlegen, wie man das Wissen rüberbringt, präsentiert. Ich würde tatsächlich heute gerne nochmal in die Schule gehen. Ich würde mich gerne nochmal neben ein 14-jähriges Mädchen setzen und auch, also klar, die Bank ist für mich recht gross, deswegen müsste man vielleicht mal ein bisschen enger zusammenrücken, das wäre aber okay für mich und ich würde mich dann irgendwie in die letzte Reihe. Würdest du Parfüm auflegen? Ich würde tatsächlich ein bisschen Parfüm auflegen, ich würde ein paar Pommes dabei haben und ich würde ein paar Gummibärchen dabei haben. Und noch mal ein paar Salzgags raushauen. Und meine Katze würde ich auch dabei haben. Ui, deine Hand ist komplett zerkratzt. Ja, heute war es ein krasser Tag. Du hast mir gesagt, dass es dir nicht gut geht privat. Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Angst, dass du dich entweder selbst verletzt und vorgibst, eine Katze zu besitzen. Wäre aber nicht schlecht. Ne, meine Katze. Und ich habe halt mit der Katze gespielt, mit so einem Faden, dann ist sie dem Faden hinterhergelaufen. Und ich habe mir überlegt, ich drehe mich einfach immer im Kreis und halte den Faden so vor mich. Ja, bestimme ist, dass du dann zuerst versagst. Das war nämlich genau die Frage. Wer bricht als erstes zusammen, die Katze oder ich? Die Katze hat gewonnen, ich bin dann gegen die Tür gefallen. Und dann war ich bewusstlos für zwei Stunden. Und dann tatsächlich war ich zu faul, um weiter mit der Katze zu spielen, dann habe ich einfach die Schnur um die Katze geknotet und die einfach machen lassen. Und die hat dann immer diesen Faden gefangen, der aber an ihr selber dran hing. Ich finde auch, wenn man mit Kindern spielt, kann ich mich so eine Stunde lang dafür begeistern und denke mir neue Dinge aus und so. Und dann ist es ein bisschen wie bei dem Podcast, irgendwann denkt man so, jetzt mach du auch mal was und dann geben einem so auch die Ideen aus, so was zu machen. Und dann hat man dann, das Kind will ja wirklich dann acht Stunden, ich wollte fast sagen, beglückt werden, bespaßt werden und begattet werden, genau wie so eine Katze, die haben dann einfach Bock und du selbst denkst, ja, ein bisschen langweilig wird schon. Das Podcast-Phänomen. Deswegen muss man, ich glaube, ein Luftballon ist auch sehr gut, ein Luftballon mit Helium so an die Decke, so dass die Schnur runterhängt, dann zieht die Katze den immer wieder runter und dann wechselt die Position und dann kann die immer wieder hochspringen und alles in der Richtung und ist tatsächlich, ja ganz gut, und die Katze hat mir tatsächlich die Hose runtergezogen, das war glaube ich so eine Situation, wie man die so, wie man in so einem Ups-Die-Pan-Show, da habe ich so die Schnur so an mir hochgehalten und dann ist sie halt so über meine Hose hochgerannt und hat sich in die Hose geklammert und dann ist sie runtergerutscht und das war ein Lustiges, da habe ich laut gelacht, die Katze war ein bisschen beschämt, aber ich hätte es vielleicht auch ein bisschen gefallen.
Und dann dachte ich mir, ah, it's the prank cat into my heart, it's the prank cat in my Wohnung, like it's the prank cat chasing das Schnur, it's the prank cat comes in meine Hose aus, was macht ihr als nächstes, wir wissen es nicht. Pranket, hat mich tatsächlich daran erinnert, dass ich mal, ich weiss nicht, du kannst dich wahrscheinlich noch an, lass uns mal über Ups die Panische. Warte mal ganz kurz, du gehst mir gerade zu schnell durch die Themen durch. Ich wollte erst mal sagen, ich habe am Wochenende war ich auf einer wilden Party, feuchtfröhlich, wow, da ist Alkohol geflossen in Wasserfällen. Bitte schreibt genau in die Kommentare, ab welchem Punkt ihr die Story nicht mehr glaubt. Und dann gab es einen Hund, Mona hieß der, und der ist elf Jahre alt und dann dachte ich mir, okay, wie viele sind das in Hundejahren? Das ist genau meine Zielgruppe. Wow, das sind 77 D-Mark, habe ich den Gag gemacht, kam überhaupt nicht an, sind aber 77 Hundejahre, das heißt, der ist uralt, der Hund, und dann wollte er, er lief er die ganze Zeit zu mir mit einem Tennisball, aber alte Hunde riechen, riechen ganz streng und es war ein bisschen unangenehm, weil er wollte einfach nur spielen, hat mir immer diesen Tennisball gereicht, aber der Tennisball hat so gequollen, so Eiter oder alles, was aus dem Mund kam und so einen Scheiss und da habe ich erst mal nicht getraut, den Ball anzufassen und dann habe ich ihn quasi genommen, habe ihn weggeschmissen, aber ein bisschen zu weit, weil der Hund ist halt sehr, sehr alt, aber auch sehr, sehr lang. Und das ist ein bisschen wie bei Family Guy, der Hund von Herbert, der Pädophilen. Genau der gleiche Hund, einfach unfassbar langsam, dann hat er irgendwann auch so Probleme mit seinem Arnus tatsächlich. Och Gott, das juckt dann halt. Not schlachtet den Typen doch. Und dann rutscht er halt immer mit seinem Hintern über den Teppichboden, weil das halt angenehm ist für ihn, und zieht dann halt wie so eine Spur hinter sich her.
Wirklich unangenehm. Also Hunde sollte man dann im gewissen Alter auch töten. Gott, das wäre ne. Tatsächlich aber dieser 77-D-Mark-Gag ist ein guter Gag. Den kann man immer wieder anbringen, wenn es darum geht, was umzubringen. Ich habe ja mal überlegt, ich habe tatsächlich mit so einem ähnlichen Gag meine Beziehung ruiniert.
Und zwar ein Freund von mir hat so eine Frau gedatet und es lief eigentlich ganz gut, aber man wusste nicht so genau, es ist noch nicht viel passiert, aber es war so ein bisschen so, hey, kann mehr passieren oder nicht und er hat so ein bisschen geflirtet und wollte so die nächste Stufe eingehen. Und wer ist dieser Freund? Macht keinen Sinn, weil du was cooles erzählst. Es ist nicht du, Stefan, okay? Es tut mir leid, aber es ist leider nicht du. Und natürlich mit dem Freund habe ich dann so ein bisschen auch überlegt, weil ich da viele Tweets geschrieben habe. Und dann kam mir die Tweet-Idee so von wegen, in Hundejahren hatten wir sieben Minuten lang Sex, war so die Aussage, so der One-Liner. Und haben wir überlegt, okay, ist ja gut oder nicht, habe mich dann dagegen entschieden. Aber er dachte, es wäre eine gute Möglichkeit, auf eine lustige Art mit ihr das Thema Sexualität zu eröffnen. So von wegen, aha, okay, cool, ich bin offen für sowas, ich weiss, wie das funktioniert, ich kenne mich aus. Hat diesen Gag ihr geschrieben, in Hundejahren hatten wir sieben Minuten lang Sex und es ging komplett nach hinten los. Sie hat geschrieben, nee, wir hatten überhaupt keinen Sex. aber auch gut, dass sie meint, dass das irgendwie diskussionswürdig wäre. Ja, genau. Weil es ist eine Tatsache, die gerade gesprochen wird. Vor allem dachte sie, dass sie vergewaltigt wurde im Schlaf oder was? Und dann ging es rapide bergab, weil er noch ein paar mehr Gags gemacht hat und es ging einfach komplett bergab. Und es hat nicht funktioniert. Wegen meines Gags hat er vielleicht die Liebe seines Lebens verloren. Sprache ist eine Waffe. Ja, vor allem schlechte Comedy ist eine sehr effektive Waffe. Ich glaube, man könnte viele Kriege auswiesen. Das ist eine sehr stumpfe Waffe, aber wenn du sehr oft drauf haust, dann ist es doch brutal. Das ist vielleicht wie so ein Schwert, das sehr stumpf ist, aber sehr schwer. Ja, oder so ein rostiger Nagel. Ja, an der richtigen Stelle, ja, richtig schwer. Was war eigentlich der dümmste Grund für den Ausbruch eines Konflikts? Für den Tod. Achso, für den Ausbruch eines Konflikts. Stimmt das eigentlich mit Troja und Helena, dass sie wirklich wegen dieser Frage, das ist doch nur Legende, oder? Ich glaube diese ganze Sache nicht. Ich glaube das von vorne bis hinten nicht. Das Trojanische Pferd, ich habe gestern eine 9-11-Doku geguckt, ich glaube gar nichts mehr jetzt. Ohne Scheisse, das Trojanische Pferd, das Trojanische Pferd dann nicht existiert, mit Sicherheit nicht. Die Türme, das World Trade Center gab es nämlich gar nicht. Was ich mich immer frage, war dieses trojanische Pferd die erste Idee oder welche Ideen haben die verworfen, bevor sie, also in den Geschichtsschreibungen, die Trojaner haben ja gewonnen, das heisst, sie können die Geschichte im Nachhinein schreiben. Und diese ganzen peinlichen Versuche... Ganz kurz, die Trojaner haben nicht gewonnen. Doch. Die haben verloren, gerade wegen des... Ah ja, gut, Die Griechen haben gewonnen, aber die mit dem trojanischen Pferd haben gewonnen. Das sind nicht die Trojaner. Nur weil es das heißt, trojanisches Pferd, weiss ich. Ja, ja, ja, ich weiss. So, auf jeden Fall hatten die die Möglichkeit, in der Geständigkeitsteilung später die ganzen misslungenen ersten Versuche zu kaschieren. Irgendwie, dass sie sich überlegt haben, so, wir bauen ein riesiges Fischernetz und werfen es über die gesamte Stadt und versuchen, die dann alle einzufangen. Wir wissen noch nicht genau, was Glas ist, aber wir machen eine grosse Glaskuppel über die Stadt. Wir bauen ein riesiges Gummiband und spannen es zwischen uns und das Tor der Stadt. Oder lassen wir uns dagegen flitschen. Und flitschen einzelne Soldaten dagegen. Ich schau mir das vor wie so eine Castingshow, so der König von Griechenland, sitzt so, wer hat Ideen? Ideen, wir brauchen Ideen. Longus Longus, Ideen. Genau, so Höhle der Löwen mässig. Genau, die ganzen Ingenieure, die besten Ingenieure in Griechenland sind extra angereist. Hier ist mein Businessplan. Stefan so, ach scheisse, ich hab nix, Alter, kannst du mir nicht irgendwas geben? Alles klar, wir brauchen eine grosse, eine, wir greifen die Stadt einfach an erstmal. Haben wir schon dreimal versucht, wir haben sehr viele Soldaten verloren, das hat nicht
funktioniert.
Mit auf Drachen.
Es gibt keinen Drachen, aber sehr gut, die Idee mag ich, vielleicht diese Drachen, die
man in die Luft hängt.
Ja, die über die Stadtmauer fliegt, aber wie kommt man, man fliegt über die Stadtmauer
und dann?
Lässt man sich fallen, in so einem Bettlaken fängt ein Stösst, quasi, dass man wie so Aber dann müssen die hier unten das Bettlaken aufhalten. Oder meinst du, wir sind das Falsche? Ja, aber das werden die schon tun. Meinst du nicht? Und wir graben einen Tunnel? Unter der Stadt her, um dann von der anderen Seite anzugreifen. Damit rechnen die nie. Wir bauen einen riesigen hölzernen Frosch, setzen uns alle da rein, alle lachen, ha ha ha, ein Frosch, lächerlich. Pferd! Keiner lacht mehr, alle gucken sich an, einer steht auf, klatscht langsam. Aber wie lang waren die Beine von diesem Pferd? Also damit da eine ganze Armee reinpasst, muss der Körper ja wirklich riesengroß sein. und dass das dann nicht die wahnsinnigen Quatsch vom Wurzeln jetzt hin gebaut haben. Weil das kannst du ja auch nicht ewig transportieren. Das heisst, die müssen es in der Nähe der Stadt gebaut haben. Und gut, es sind wahrscheinlich nicht so viele Trojaner da rumgelaufen, aber es muss doch einer gesehen haben, dass sie so ein riesen fucking Trojaner-Pferd bauen. Was ich mir da auch immer denke, ich meine, es gab doch zu der Zeit schon Spionage, oder? Wenn der Gegner so ein hunderttausend Mann starkes Heer hat, ist es so schwer, dass da so ein Typ kommt und so, hey, ich bin Bob, hi Bob, alles klar, ich komme aus der Kompanie drüben, die mit der Löwenstandarte habe ich. Ich habe jetzt meine Standarte nicht dabei, aber zu denen gehört, da kenne ich ihn und ihn. Aber das ist doch ein ganz anderes Wappen als wir. Das ist doch ein ganz anderes Wappen. Ich habe meines leider vergessen tatsächlich, deswegen hat mir Leon noch eins geliehen. Gar kein Leon? Leonidas, also der, also ne, der, der, der. Kein Problem, guck mal einfach mit bei uns. Wie heisst du nochmal? Paulus. Ist aber jetzt tatsächlich ein trojanischer Name. Jaja, ich habe trojanische Eltern. Ich heiße Bruce Wayne. Wayneo. Wayneodidas. Adidas könnte ein griechischer Name sein, oder? Adidas? Ist es ja auch, glaube ich. Meinst du? Irgendwer hat jetzt neulich seine Schuhe ausgegraben, aus die ersten antiken Schuhe, so die ersten Schuhe angeblich, die jemals gefunden wurden, und die hatten dreiifen wie Adidas. Es sah einfach eins wie ein geiler Adidas Sneaker. Es war kein Fake, es ist Science, Wissenschaft. Hatte auch einen Klettverschluss. Hatte einen Klettverschluss und hinten stand auch so Air Max drauf und so ein Scheiß. Hast du Ötzi eigentlich mal gesehen? Was war Ötzi? Gesehen. Ich habe den mal gesehen, ich war in dem Museum, wo der ausgestellt ist, der ist sehr klein tatsächlich. Welchem Museum denn? Irgendwo in Bayern, in den Alten oder zwischen Italien und Österreich, in der Gegend, ich glaube, da wurde auch gefunden. Der ist sehr klein, der ist sehr klein, ja. Aber es ist erstaunlich, wie stark sich die Menschen dann doch verändert haben in der Zeit, weil der ist so gross wie ein Kind, also so gross wie ein 14-jähriges Mädchen irgendwie ist sehr gross. Und da ist man ja schon ein ganzes Stück grösser, also das geht mir ungefähr hier bis unter die Brust oder so ein bisschen.
Und ich frage mich halt, wie sich die Menschheit weiterentwickeln wird.
Was sind deine Top 5, also wir machen ganz, Top 5, die Top 5 Arten, wie man beschäftigt aussieht, ohne wirklich beschäftigt zu sein.
Habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Nummer 5.
Was? Wie kommt denn das jetzt?
Man antwortet auf Mails immer eine halbe Stunde zu spät. Ganz kurz, das, nee, nee, nee, das ist mir jetzt zu weird, das ist mir zu Florentin-Style jetzt. Erstmal auf die Frage eingehen nochmal. Wie sich Menschen weiterentwickeln? Ich glaube nicht mehr, also ich glaube, dass sie nicht mehr grösser werden, weil, also es entwickelt sich ja alles dahin jetzt, okay, der Körper merkt, dass wir selber unsere Mittel haben, beziehungsweise was überweise wir wachsen uns kein Fell mehr, wir laufen auf zwei Beinen, deswegen geht das Steissbein
langsam zurück, das ist immer noch ein Überrest von dem Schwanz, den man hatte früher.
Also entwickelt sich alles in die Richtung so, man braucht weniger Hilfsmittel und dadurch,
glaube ich, auch werden wir langsam wieder kleiner.
Was war eigentlich vor?
Weil man wurde ja immer nur grösser, um immer grössere Hecken des Nachbarn gucken
zu können.
Und jetzt hat man ja Drohnen und so, und dann merkt der Körper ja auch, okay, anscheinend braucht man mich nicht mehr, Wachstumshormonen, dann gehe ich halt, dann gehe ich halt, Evolution, tschau. Aber dass der Mensch vom Affen abstammt, ist ja glaube ich relativ klar. Aber was kam vor dem Affen? Fisch einfach, oder nicht? Direkt Fisch, dann wurde direkt ein Abe da drauf. Von einem auf den anderen Tagen, da kann man sich auch, what, was ist denn jetzt passiert, wer bin ich? Ja, aber wirklich, also, wenn man diese, es ist doch immer so Einzeller irgendwas, dann hast du diesen Fisch, so in diesem Fatboy Slim Video, diesen Fisch, der schwimmt dann, der fällt dann irgendwie durch einen dummen Zufall auf den Strand und merkt, oh, auch ganz geil. Ich glaube, die Evolution hat sich an dem Fatboy Slim-Video orientiert. Glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, da gab es so einen Masterplan. Right here, right now. Guter Song. Die 90er, lasst du einfach die 90er zurück in der Erlebe. Es macht alles Sinn, wie das passiert ist. Die ganze Evolution, ich finde, jeder Schritt ist die logische Konsequenz aus den Dingen, die davor passiert sind. Das ist Determinismus. Alles, was kommt, ist ein Produkt aus dem, was vorher passiert ist. Ja, aber spricht man dem Sinn nicht eigentlich erst retroaktiv zu, dass man sagt, alles, wie es entstanden ist, hat Sinn. Somit ist die Aussage, Evolution hat Sinn, ist eigentlich sinnlos, weil wir Sinn nur dadurch definieren, dass es durch die Evolution entstanden ist. Ich möchte das weiterführen und sagen, dass angenommen, wir begegnen irgendwann mal extraterrestrischen Lebensformen, dass die, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt großartig anders aussehen als wir. Weil wenn Leben entsteht, ist der Abstand ungefähr gleich, die Grösse des Planeten ungefähr gleich. Es ist so viel gleich, dass es eigentlich keinen Sinn macht, dass die grossartig anders entwickeln. Da werden auch erst Dinge im Wasser gelebt haben, werden sich weiterentwickelt haben. Es ist halt immer der nächste Schritt... Was ist, wenn es da kein Wasser gibt, wenn die ersten Lebewesen in Gestein entstanden sind? Ja, ist halt sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil die intelligenten Wesen nicht wahrscheinlich in Steinen stehen. Warum ist keiner Steinwesen? Der Durchschnitt des Universums, glaube ich, sieht exakt aus wie wir. Exakt wie du, glaube ich sogar. Genau, exakt wie die ganze Welt, wo nur Stephans rumlaufen. Die Aliens kommen und die gesamte Rasse sieht exakt so aus wie Wie unkühl das für mich wäre als Erden-Stefan. Und alle gucken sich aber auch gegenseitig die ganze Zeit so an. Sorry. Ich gehe noch einen Kommentar los, du den ins Uf und weg. Hört meinen Podcast an, ich habe einen Podcast. Das Podcast-Auto heißt das dann. Alle, die zum Beispiel tief unter Wasser leben, haben ja sehr grosse Augen. Die haben auch so eine Lampe vor sich hängen. Manche sind so Unterwasserfisch mit der Lampe vor sich. Was auch… Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das stimmt. Also ich bin wirklich gerade… Du bist sehr skeptisch. Dabei ist jetzt… Zum Beispiel letztens… Ja, ich bin auch sehr skeptisch, seit der 9-11-Doku. Ich hatte eine Diskussion über Amazonen und da hieß es von wegen… Amazonen. Amazonen, ja nicht Amazon, Amazonen. Ja, Retzagen, okay. Und die haben sich ja ihre Brüste abgeschnitten, damit sie besser Bogen schießen. Die Sabinerinnen. Und dann habe ich überlegt, ob sie sich nur die linke Brust abgeschnitten haben oder beide. Und ob das nicht eigentlich eine sehr maskuline Sicht der Dinge ist, dass die Frau das, was ihre Weiblichkeit ausdrückt, entfernen muss, um Krieger sein zu können. Das ist ja eine sehr maskuline Art. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, es gab ja überhaupt keine Amazon wahrscheinlich. Ich dachte immer, das wäre so wie Griechen und Trojaner, aber eigentlich gab es die nicht. Doch, das meine ich gibt schon. Also es war ins Museum gehen. Amazon? Ich glaube nicht, das ist hier mal als Amazon da. Es gab den Stamm der Sabinerinnen. Ja gut, das ist ein Witz, aber... Nee. Sabinerinnen? Die Sabinerinnen, und die haben ihre Brüste abgeschnitten, und da war das so ein kriegerisches Raubvolk. Auf jeden Fall gab es das. Warum hatten die denn keine Männer? Wie entwickelt sich das denn organisch, dass eine Gesellschaft sagt? Das hat absolut keinen Sinn. Das ist auch so. Es ergibt wirklich keinen Sinn. Also eher würden die Männer die Frauen rausschmeissen. Ich weiss es nicht, ey. Das ist echt... Oh, kurz, wenn das so Entschuldigung, jetzt sind gerade interne Gespräche werden ausserhalb des Fensters geführt. Wenn er also ganz laut den Podcast laut dreht, könnte er gleich vielleicht so interner aufschnatten. Ja, genau. What? Das Neomagazin bald in 3D? Oh mein Gott! Jetzt habe ich es gesagt. Ups. Spannend. Evolution finde ich spannend. Lass uns mal einen schlauen Menschen in diesen Podcast einladen, da habe ich mal Lust drauf. Muss nicht berühmt sein, aber irgendwie so ein Museumskurator oder so. Wer ist der schlaueste Mensch, den du kennst? Mein Deutschlehrer. Mein ehemaliger Deutschlehrer, glaube ich. Der war sehr schlau? Unfassbar, der wusste sehr viel. Und ein sehr belesener, mies gelaunter Mensch. Ich finde es interessant, dass du momentan zur Uni gehst und keine der Professoren kommen dann deinen Deutschlehrer an. Ja, ich kenne die halt nicht so gut. Also früher hat man mit den Lehrern mehr Zeit verbracht, auch so wenn es dann Richtung Ferien geht und man dann irgendwie so Spiele gemacht hat in der Klasse. Das war auch immer ganz herrlich. Und da hat man sich auch kennengelernt. Aber in der Uni, wenn man halt mal eine Vorlesung hat, dann ist der Professor danach weg. Kenn ich nicht. Was war das Komplizierteste, das du jemals verstanden hast? Ich glaube, so Astronomie-Zeugs. Ich glaube so, ähm... Die Tatsache, dass es Astronomie-Zeug nennt. So Astronomie ... Wie nennt man das? So Astrolo-Astrolo-Horoskope oder so. Was davon? Der Tunneleffekt. Das ist ja der Grund. Der Tunneleffekt ist eigentlich nicht erklärbar. Es ist nämlich so ein Grund, warum kleinste Teilchen eigentlich nicht da sein sollten, wo sie sind, weil sie durch etwas durchspringen, in Überlichtgeschwindigkeit, was eigentlich gar nicht sein sollte, und deswegen explodieren Sonnen nicht. Weil Sonnen, eigentlich sind Sonnen ja so heiß, dass andauernd Kernfusion entstehen müsste und die Sonne immer größer werden würde, aber durch diesen Tunneleffekt, weil die Teilchen nicht da sein sollten, wo sie sind, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die ich jetzt nicht wieder verstanden habe. Ich dachte, gerade durch den Tunneleffekt entsteht die Kernfusion, dass die Teichchen so extrem heiß werden, dass sie so geschnitten wegen gefährlichem Halbwissen. Also durch den Tunneleffekt ist es unmöglich. Ist wissenschaftlich nicht so ganz erklärbar. Aber du hast es gerade erklärt. Ich habe es verstanden. Ich habe es glaube ich verstanden. Nobelpreis. Glaubst du, wer von uns ist näher an einem Nobelpreis dran? Wir sind ja beide sehr weit weg davon, aber wer ist näher von uns an einem Nobelpreis dran? Ich würde sagen, du, denn du hast ja dein angefangenes Buch zu schreiben. Yes! Literaturnobelpreis incoming. Wie läuft's? Ich habe jetzt das erste Kapitel geschrieben. Wie lang ist es ungefähr? Und ich weiß schon, es ist nicht lang, es sind lang, es sind kurze Kapitel. Wie lang denn? Einerhalb Seiten. Und jetzt geht es weiter. Und wie viele Kapitel hat das Buch? Drei? Es ist zwei Kapitel. Und das zweite ist aber nur einen Satz lang. Und der humoristisch endet es dann. Aber es ist trotzdem, will ich gerne auf 214 Seiten das gedruckt haben. Aber es soll halt so ein bisschen so ein Gag sein quasi. Weil alle Seiten zu befüllen, kennt man ja, aber jetzt ist mal ein Metagag quasi, dass nur zwei Kapitel quasi ausgeschrieben sind und der Rest ist leere Seiten, da steht dann oben drüber Notizen.
Du kannst dir wahrscheinlich vorstellen, wie alle, die in so einem Podcast hören, jetzt gerade für den Empfangsgeräten sitzen, die Zähne klappernd, wackelnd, wirr, sich im Kreis reden und sagen, Stefan, bitte erzähl uns doch, worum geht's denn?
Möchte ich nicht ersehen. Das ist ja wohl das letzte.
Nein, absolut nicht. Da gibt es gar nichts von. Ich möchte dich vorlesen, ich möchte es auch nicht, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Das würdest du auch nicht machen wollen, du hast auch schon sehr viel geschrieben, hast du mir selber gesagt, du würdest das niemals vorlesen, unfertig. Doch, ich kann dir das alles vorlesen.
Ja, okay, ja, raus! Los, los!
Egel! Ja, ich habe das nicht hier.
Ja, ich kann dir mein...
Ja, wir sind das nicht hier. Ja, haha!
Ich kann dir meinen ...
Wir sind bei dir zu Hause.
Mein Essay, den ich in der Uni geschrieben habe, kann ich dir vorlesen.
Ja, mir ist mal vor.
Der ist mega langweilig. Der ist halt philosophischer Text, sehr tiefgründig und tief.
Komm schon, einen Satz. Gib uns den ersten Satz!
Das ist aber noch nicht fertig, aber der erste Satz ist ...
Haha, das Kapitel ist fertig, aber der erste Satz ...
Der steht noch nicht ganz, aber der Stand jetzt ist, ich weiss es noch wie heute. Komma? Wie heute, Punkt. Das ist doch ein guter Satz. Ist ein guter Satz, es wurden immer die beliebtesten Buchanfänge gewählt, also die besten Buchanfänge, und der beste war ja Ilsebil Salzenach, ist von Günter Grass. Das ist der beste Buchanfang. Ist guter Satz. Ilsebil salztenach, ist schon ganz schön cool. Ist schon gut. Du bist mittendrin und weisst genau wo, wahrscheinlich in der Küche, wahrscheinlich kocht sie gerade, es geht um Ilsebil. Aber ist das schon ein Gag, ne, aber es heisst ja eigentlich, ich weiss es noch wie gestern. Also es ist schon ein Gag, ne, ich weiss es noch wie Oder habe ich das jetzt falsch verhofft? Nö, es wird ein Gag mit dem letzten Satz des Kapitels. Es war heute dann, oder? Das Ganze war vor drei Tagen, aber das dazwischen drin ist halt so extrem krass, was da passiert. Es ist schliesslich nicht ganz der Gag, erst wenn man das Kapitel liest. Ich wollte eigentlich am Anfang noch was erzählen über Upsi-Pan-Show, aber da hast du mich ja wüst unterbrochen. Was ist das denn, wo fuhlt das denn hin? Dass ich tatsächlich mal, früher ist es ja Upsdie-Pannenshow, und da hieß es immer am Ende, oder ganz am Anfang der Sendung oder sowas, hieß es immer, einsenden. Genau, einsenden. Wer uns das beste Video einsendet, kriegt tausend Mal. Und dann hast du es nachgestellt. Und dann habe ich versucht, so ein Pannenvideo zu faken. Podcast-Ufo zweite Folge. Zweite Folge? Ich glaube, wir glaube, wir haben es so langsam, oder? Wir sind durch. Wir sind einmal jetzt. Ich glaube, wir haben es eigentlich. Wir haben den Kreis abgeschlossen. Aber es ist wirklich schwierig, weil man weiss ja nicht mehr, was man alles schon erzählt hat. Das ist ja jetzt eineinhalb Jahre her. Ich wollte ja nicht erzählen, ich war heute im Megazoo. Der Laden heißt so, Zooladen halt, Megazoo. Und das habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt. Da haben wir auch schon drüber Gags gemacht, dass es so heisst und das ist ein riesen Zooladen einfach.
Aber ich finde es immer, ich finde, dein Leben ist wirklich undurchdringbar.
Ich verstehe immer nicht, was du machst.
Einerseits sagst du, du bist halt so Slacker, ein Nerd, dass du zu Hause rumsitzt und den ganzen Tag Serien schaust und Bücher liest und so.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite heisst du wieder, ja, ich war gestern in SeaWorld alleine oder so.
Nee, es ist ein Zooladen halt. Ich brauche da was für mein Aquarium.
Ist jetzt nicht so, weil, Achtung, auch ein geiler Anmachspruch, ich habe ein Algenproblem. Ja, erzähl uns bitte mehr. Was ist los mit Jeff, wie geht es ihm? Gut, gut, schwimmt rum, locker, freudig, schöne Gesichtsfarbe, hat er gesunde Farbe. Ja, geniesst er die Sonne. Geniesst, ja. Stellst du ihn manchmal in die Sonne? Ich glaube, das Algenproblem könnte an der Sonne liegen, bin mir nicht sicher, weil keine Sonne reinkommt. Also Pflanzen sind ja sehr anspruchsvoll und Algen nicht so. Das heißt, wenn so ein Mindestbedarf an Nährstoffen da sind, bilden sich zunächst erstmal Algen daraus. Wir nehmen halt die Pflanzen dann überhand, wenn es sich ausgeglichen hat. Es ist nicht so interessant, ne? Jetzt haben wir einfach ... Glaubst du, was ist das uninteressanteste Haustier? Haustier? Ja. Boah, ich glaube, er ist auf der einen Seite ... Ich glaube, so eine Spinne, so eine Vogelspinne. So eine Vogelspinne. Ja. Ist natürlich cool zu erzählen, so ich habe eine Vogelspinne und dann ... Ja, cool. Aber dann war es das auch, weil die machen ja nichts. Die sitzen, die können auch in so einem ganz kleinen Terrarium sein, so 15 x 15 cm, dann sitzen die da halt drin, den ganzen Tag. Ich finde, Fisch ist schon relativ weit oben. Also es hat natürlich auch eine gewisse Coolness, die Frage, ob du es eher als Deko siehst oder eher als Lebenspartner, so ein Tier. So ein Lebensabschnittspartner. So eine Katze ist natürlich cool, mit der kann man interagieren, die erzählt Geschichten, die hat Storys, die tötet dich fast, du hast den Puls alle nicht mehr. Die hat Sachen, die kann man ausbilden, irgendwie zu einer Kampfkatze ausbilden und sowas, da ist eine gewisse Narrative da, da kann man Geschichten erzählen. Aber halt so ein Fisch, der ist halt mehr Deko. Kampffisch halt nicht, weil Kampffische sind ja auch zum Kämpfen ausgebildet, die wurden ja, die haben ja in ihren Genen eine jahrelange Manipulation hin zum Kampf. Es wurden damals in Taiwan oder wo er immer nachherkommt, so aus der Ecke, da haben die dann halt die Fische dazu gezüchtet, gegeneinander zu kämpfen. Und dann wurden Kampffische, weil die halt ihr Territorium verteidigen, haben die die halt schön und aggressiv gezüchtet und quasi komplett lebensunfähig.
Die können auch nicht gut schwimmen, lieber halt einfach im Wasser, das ist ein grosser Nachteil. Und dann haben die die halt so dressiert, dass wenn die in ein Aquarium gesetzt werden, sich sofort töten einfach. Und das ist halt schon ganz geil. Das ist eine coole Eigenschaft. Aber die sind dann für immer alleine, oder nicht? Ja, die müssen für immer alleine sein. Ausser du kannst ein Weibchen reinsetzen und dann... Weibchen töten die ja nicht. Nee, einen kurzen Zeitraum nicht, wenn sie fruchtbar sind. Dann bringt das Weibchen dann die Kinder zur Welt und dann tötet das Männchen das Weibchen. Und die Kinder. Und die Kinder. Das ist ein bisschen ärgerlich. Clever. Du musst ihn direkt trennen. Man müsste immer so eine Sendung machen, Best-of der ausgestorbenen Tierarten und warum sie ausgestorben aber wo wir gerade bei evolution waren das verstehe ich ja also bei meiner theorie dass alles sinnhaftig verläuft und jetzt alles logisch ist passen halt die dinosaure überhaupt nicht rein weil das ist so unwirklich das ist so dass sie so groß sind ich meine der planet hat eine gewisse ich glaube dass die grösse eines lebewesen unsere grösse auch mit der schwerkraft natürlich mega viel zu tun hat, weil es die sinnhaftigste Grösse ist für ein intelligentes Lebewesen. Aber warum hat das irgendwann mal die Evolution halt Dinosaurier hervorgebracht, die einfach so 15 Meter gross sind? Ich habe auch mal gehört, dass es irgendwas mit der Beschaffenheit der Atmosphäre zu tun haben könnte, dass die Luftzusammenstellung anders war und man grössere Organe einfach gebraucht hat, um es irgendwie auszustellen und sowas. Das kann natürlich sein. Und ich meine natürlich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Blätter oben am Baum und so, die muss halt immer grösser werden und so und dann die Raubtiere müssen auch immer grösser werden, um die grösseren anderen zu fressen und so und dann halt irgendwie nochmal kompletter Kurzschluss, weil die Drecksäugetiere halt so klein waren, dass sie denen die Eier klauen konnten und damit haben die halt nicht gerechnet. Da dachte ich, ja fuck, da haben wir jetzt überhaupt nichts geplant irgendwie. Wir können keine Zäune bauen, wir haben viel zu grosse Hände, der Hammer ist viel zu klein. Das schaffe ich nicht, müssen wir aussterben, lassen wir es halt. So, und dann haben die halt auch aufgegeben und haben gesagt, wir haben jetzt keinen Bock mehr. Und es wurden dann daraus Vögel. Die Vögel stammen ja von den Dysauriern ab, wohin gegen wir nicht. Aber die Designer, wirklich, das haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal, aber ich finde das immer wieder interessant, wie so eine gewisse Vorstellung von Dingen sich einfach nicht töten lässt. Zum Beispiel Steven Spielberg redet Jurassic Park und er inszeniert diese Dinosauriern, hat er dann einfach einen Designentwurf, der jetzt vielleicht nicht naturwissenschaftlich korrekt ist, aber halt auch schon fundiert. Und dann sehen diesen Film tausende Kinder, die alle sagen, oh, ich will Dinosaurierforscher werden. Das heißt, all diese Dinosaurierforscher gehen in diese Dinosaurierforschung mit diesem Bild von Dinosauriern im Kopf. Die lieben das, die finden das cool, die mögen das, das ist ihr Traum mit Dinosauriern zu tun haben und die werden natürlich nicht akzeptieren, dass die ganz anders aussehen und Vögel waren und halt total scheisse aussehen.
Was Federn hatten. Und deswegen werden die Forschungsergebnisse ignorieren oder halt nicht publizieren oder so.
Das kriegst du nicht mehr raus.
Unsere Folge vier oder so, wo ich dann erzählt habe, dass ich eine Doku geguckt habe über den Triceratops.
Triceratops?
El Triceratops. Und der hat halt diese grossen Hörner, die also sinnbildlich für ihn sind.
Diese grossen drei Hörner auf der Nase und auf der Stirn. Und die waren angeblich, dachte man ja, laufen die miteinander rein, das ist der Paarungskampf und so. Nein, die waren so Pappmaché-artigem Material, einfach so sehr zerbrechlich. Wenn du es einfach anfasst, dann fällt es schon in sich zusammen so, dass die gar nicht damit gekämpft haben, sondern es einfach nur so ein Witz der Natur war und dass dieses grosse Schild, was die hatten, auch irgendwie so einfach biegsam ist, wie so Fingernagel, einfach so mega uncool. Und das war dann zur Abschreckung oder was? Ja, also so, wo man auch denkt, nee, eigentlich nein, die sind doch, die waren zum Kämpfen da. Wo man sich das selber so einredet, die hatten Federn, hm. Ja, ich habe auch gelesen, dass wenn du einem Löwen gegenüberstehst, dann sollst du dir eine Jacke aufmachen und die so ausbreiten, weil Löwen anscheinend stark nicht in der Tiefe sehen, sondern halt nur so in der Fläche. Das heißt, das Objekt wirkt dann riesengross, nur weil es sehr breit ist. Ich lade das so Exhibitionisten-mäßig, er führt die Jacke auf. Vielleicht ist es auch nur von den Löwen gestreut, damit sie einfach ein bisschen was zu sehen bekommen. Man weiß es nicht genau. Genau, laufen sie auf die schöne Frau. Ja, mach die Jackengeste. Oder wie diese Schlangen, von denen man sich erst halb essen lassen soll, so bis zur Hüfte, und erst dann nimmt man seine, also die Schlange frisst dich, will dich auffressen, und dann hast du ein Messer, und dann kann es sich nicht mehr verteidigen, dann kannst du so langsam aufschneiden. Das finde ich auch ganz, ich finde Schlangen auch so seltsam, weil die essen ja dann, also die haben ja dann die Form des Dings, was sie gefressen haben. Wenn sie einen Fernseher fressen, dann haben sie halt so, dann haben sie ja so ein Viereck in sich drin.
Die übernehmen auch die Fähigkeiten. Also wenn die auch dann was mit Beinen essen, dann können die auch die Beine benutzen, dann können die auch gehen. Wohingegen wenn sie ein Rollband fressen, sich quasi wie so ein Panzer vorbewegen können.
Ja.
Clever, diese Schlangen. Aber das finde ich auch so seltsam. Und dann haben die, was haben die, so Säuren im Magen, was ist dann zersetzt langsam. Da denkt man auch, es ist doch vorher. Ja, aber die kauen das gar nicht, die schlucken das einfach runter. Schlucken das einfach runter. Aber vor allem die haben ja auch nicht, also die bestehen ja nur aus, die bestehen ja nur aus Hals, also wo, das ist ja so komisch, ist dann irgendwo, haben die da so eine Halspartie oder ist das alles Magen einfach, die gesamte Schlange ist Magen. Ganz die doch so ganz zurückgebildet, so kleine Ärmchen irgendwo, das würde mich auch interessieren. Die haben bestimmt so ganz
ganz winzig klein zurückgebildet, so ganz kleine Ärmchen, die man nicht sieht.
Ja, wie so Pichs, ganz kleine so. Die haben immer winken, aber man sieht's nicht.
Der Arm kämpft noch ums Überleben, so drei Generationen und ich bin weg.
Ciao! Er winkt, er winkt. Waves goodbye.
Ja, genau, der Evolution, goodbye. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe mal so ein Buch gelesen über so wissenschaftliche Phänomene, die man sich lange nicht erklären konnte, bis irgendjemand eine zündende Idee hatte. Und da gab es auch irgendein... Bis sie irgendeine falsche Idee hatte und man hat auch gesagt, es ist einfach ganz... Bis sie gemerkt hat, dass die Fragestellung vollkommen falsch ist. Und da gab es auch so ein Wesen, da konnte man sich immer nicht erklären, warum irgendwie so ein Organ irgendwie erst oben war und dann auf der Unterseite. Der Kopf, warum der auch runtergewandert ist. Nee, irgendwie so der Darm oder so war einmal auf der Oberseite und dann immer späteren Evolutionsstufe war er auf der Unterseite des Körpers. Und man kann sich nicht erklären, wie das passiert ist, weil der kann ja nicht langsam gewandert sein, weil sobald er nicht mehr an der Oberfläche ist, funktioniert es einfach nicht mehr so.
Also das Ganze grob vereinfacht. Der kann nicht einfach einmal durch den Körper durchgewandert sein.
Und dann haben wir überlegt, wie kann das sein? Und tatsächlich sind die zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es gut sein kann, dass sie irgendwann einfach angefangen haben, rückwärts zu schwimmen.
So auch so ein Fischviech, dass sie einfach irgendwann alle auf den Bauch geschwommen sind, alle, weil das irgendwie besser war und sich dann im Umkehrschluss die ganzen Gliedmassen und alle so entwickelt haben, dass sie sich wieder umgedreht und normal schwimmen konnten. Das heißt, sie haben sich einmal komplett umgedreht und alles wieder angepasst und waren dann einfach einmal durchgeswitcht von den inneren Organen her. Wir haben uns ja auch neulich über die Flunder unterhalten sehr lange. Eines der wenigen asymmetrischen Tiere tatsächlich. Asymmetrische Tierarten.
Ja.
Und die gibt es ja auch, die wirklich auch auf der Seite schwimmen quasi, aber der Mund noch an der Seite hängt und ein Auge nach oben. Die haben beide Augen auf einer Seite. Beide Augen oben, aber der Mund ist noch so an der Seite halt befindlich. Der wandert auch, glaube ich, dann von Generation zu Generation langsam nach unten. Das ist ein Rochen. Das ist ein behinderte Bruder auf der Evolutionsstufe zum Rochen hin. Ja, vor allem die, die Rochen müssen die flundern sehen und denken, pfff, was ist das denn?
Aber sind dann alle Linksträger oder sind auch manche andersrum?
Also wenn die jetzt, die liegen auf der rechten Seite und haben dann beide Augen auf der linken Seite oder sind alle gleich?
Ich glaube, es sind alle gleich.
Aber auch interessant, dass sich das dann so entwickelt hat, dass alle plötzlich links, da muss dann ein so ein Trendsetter gewesen sein.
Es herrscht so ein Bürgerkrieg plötzlich zwischen den Linksträgern und den Rechtsträgern und dann greifen die sich an und dann schwimmen sie ineinander rein.
Das ist ein Schuss. plötzlich links, da muss dann ein so ein Trendsetter gewesen sein. Es herrscht so ein Bürgerkrieg plötzlich zwischen den Linksträgern und den Rechtsträgern und dann greifen die sich an und dann schwimmen sie einander rein und es kommt ein normaler Fisch raus. Ja, oder irgendwann hat sich die Temperatur verändert und die Linksträger hatten aus dem Grund, weil die Sonne dann von links einstrahlt, irgendwie plötzlich alle keinen Bock mehr und sind alle ausgestorben. Jetzt sind wir schon in einer Fantasy. Gut. Sorry. Auch keinen Sinn ergeben jetzt. Nimmst du das zurück? Ja. Gut. Das will ich auch hoffen. Aber wie gesagt, Evolution ist spannend und ich glaube, da liegt was. Ich glaube, da ist immer was auf der Spur. Ich glaube, da könnte man mal, das müssen wir mit so einem Evolutionsbiologen oder Biologin müssen wir mal reden, da hätte ich auch Bock drauf, das finde ich auch richtig spannend, weil eigentlich, was man eigentlich immer überdenkt, ist ja, dass Evolution funktioniert durch Aussterben.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist es ja nicht so, dass die guten Ideen sich weiterentwickeln, sondern nur die schlechten Ideen werden alle rausgeschaut. Aber das ist jetzt tomato, tomato.
Nee, finde ich eben nicht.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach egal.
Ja, eben.
Du kannst sagen, die guten setzen sich durch, weil die schlechten aussterben. Nee, es ist nicht dasselbe, weil du hast gerade gesagt, alles, was in der Evolution zu finden ist, ergibt Sinn. Und da sage ich, es muss eben nicht so sein, es muss nur eben nicht schädlich sein. Wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, so ein Widder, warum sind die in diesem Senderhörner jetzt nach links gedreht und nicht nach rechts gedreht? Dann könnte man jetzt überlegen, ob das einen Sinn oder nicht, und man kann einfach sagen, es ist einfach egal. Es war einfach nie ein so grosses Problem, dass manche Wilder deswegen ausgestorben sind. Deswegen ist es einfach irrelevant. Man macht keinen Unterschied. Ja, aber das ist ja quasi, dann würdest du der Natur ja unterstellen, dass sie falsifiziert. Genau. Dass sie so lange einfach irgendwas, so ein Bullshit in die Welt aussetzt und einfach das überlebt, was am sinnhaftesten ist. Nee, andersrum, das stirbt was aus, das nicht am sinnhaftesten ist. Aber das, was funktioniert, entwickelt sich ja auch weiter. Ja, aber nur weil das wegstirbt, der Bodensatz. Also die Prämisse ist, nicht alles kann überleben und das, was sich am schlechtesten an die Umwelt angepasst hat, stirbt aus. Ja, genau so kannst du sagen, das, was sich am besten, was am besten, was passt, geht halt deinen Weg weiter. Ja, es ist eine andere Betrachtungsweise, weil es ist kein Belohnungsprinzip, sondern ein Bestrafungsprinzip. Ich glaube ja sowieso, deswegen sagt man ja auch, dass man in der
Wissenschaft am besten falsifizieren sollte, weil das das beste Prinzip ist, weil du nicht Dinge
konkret beweisen kannst, aber du kannst Dinge ausschliessen, indem du sie
widerlegst. Macht Sinn, Karl Reimund Popper, auch ein Philosoph, wo du ja, du bist ja
philosophisch versiert, da dachte ich mir, streuch ich meinen Namen, kann der mal nachlesen, Karl-Reimund-Popper-P-O-P-P-E-R, Karl-Reimund-K-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-E-M-D-A-R-M-D-A-R-M-D-A-R-MReimund-Popper, p-o-p-b-e-r, Karl-Reimund-K-a-at-b-win.c.
Check it out, check it out now.
Abonnieren, wir freuen uns, schreibt mal in die Kommentare, was euer Lieblingsphilosoph ist.
Lass uns mal die Brücke schlagen zur Musik, denn du bist ja Musiker und ich frage mich, wie hast du dein Instrument ausgewählt?
Standest du für eine konkreten Auswahl, hat dich mal jemand gefragt, was möchtest du machen, A, B oder C, oder hast du von dir selbst den Drang zu diesem, genau diesem Instrument? Es gab damals, weiß ich noch, die Diskussion, mal, da kann man nämlich ein Instrument lernen von der Musikschule, gab es dann immer so einen Flyer, hier lernt entweder Klavier oder Gitarre oder so, und dann gab es da so eine Auswahl, so eine Classic Instruments, und dann habe ich das genommen, was man am ehesten anschaffen konnte, weil es am billigsten war, was man am ehesten irgendwo hin mitnehmen konnte, damit man sich immer, wenn man selber darauf üben konnte zu Hause, aber auch das gleiche Instrument mitnehmen konnte zur Musikschule, also habe ich mich für die Gitarre entschieden. Das war so eine ganz rationale Entscheidung. Ja, ein Ausflussprinzip. Weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, weil ich meine, es gibt ja schon so Typen, also so Musikertypen, die halt einfach die, man hat das Gefühl, dass das Instrument, entweder der Karakter sich aus, das Instrument sucht den Meister. Also wenn jemand sagt, ich spiele Saxophon, dann hat er, oh das ist der Saxman, so du hast genau was vor Augen den Typen, so das ist was ganz anderes als anderes als jetzt ein Schlagzeuger. Aber das ist die Frage, muss man eigentlich das Instrument seinem Charakter anpassen oder ist es automatisch, dass alle die Saxophone wählen, eine Art Mensch sind? Ich liebe das ja, wenn man sich in Orchester betrachtet, wie die einzelnen Leute da hingekommen sind. Man sehe im Hintergrund immer den Mann mit dem Hammer, der halt den geilsten Job ist, weil er einmal in 20 Minuten mit so einem seltsamen, wirklich
hammerförmigen, so ein grosser Tor, so tormässig ein Hammer schwingt, das wirklich einfach ein
Hammer ist und auch so heisst, einfach auf so eine grosse Pauke schlägt. Nee, auf dem Holzblock,
der schlägt gar nicht auf eine Pauke. Auf die Pauke hat das halt diese grossen, diese Pushen.
Aber ist das nicht diese eine grosse Silvester-Sinfonie hier von, keine Ahnung, wo eigentlich eine Kanone abgefeuert werden sollte? Es gibt doch ein so ein klassisches Stück, ich glaube sogar dieses Ich glaube, da soll irgendwann eine Kanone abgeschossen werden, aber ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber irgendein Stück, das nämlich komponiert wurde für Silvester. Und zwar wurde das genau so komponiert, dass genau um null Uhr es genau 24 Stunden geht. Ich glaube, dass sogar genau um null Uhr die Kanone abgefeuert wird. Das war so die Idee. Und dann mussten die halt wirklich genau abpassen, wann sie anfangen und weil irgendein Trottel noch auf dem Klo war oder so, ging nicht. Du musst es in so einer gewissen Sekunde anfangen, damit genau dann alle zehn, neun, acht und dann bam steht es genau so.
In der Musik wurde auch mittlerweile, weil die Musik halt schon so lange existiert, wurde in der Musik mittlerweile fast alles irgendwann mal.
Du hast jeden Gag, glaube ich, schon drin.
Genau, und da gibt es nämlich diese grossartige Sache von John Cage, der ja, war man damals eine geniale Nebenfrage, glaube ich auch. Wie kommt es, dass in der Stadt XY alle ungefähr alle zehn Jahre, das nächste Mal ungefähr in sieben Monaten, alle dahin können und die Kirchenorgel besuchen oder so. Oder keine Ahnung, oder Sandsäckchen anbringen müssen oder sowas. Und dann war die Lösung einfach, da wird gerade das langsamste Stück der Welt aufgeführt und das geht irgendwie 700 Jahre, das Stück von John Cage. Und alle zehn Jahre wird ein Ton gespielt. Und alle zehn Jahre muss der Akkord gewechselt werden. Und dann werden mit so Sandsäckchen werden dann die Tasten beschwert. Und die spielen die ganze Zeit, oder was, einen Ton? Die spielen gerade die ganze Zeit einen Akkord. Das ist ein Stück, ganz normale Noten, eine ganz normale Partitur, aber es ist das langsamste Stück der Welt. Und in 700 Jahren irgendwann ist es fertig. Und dann kommt ein großer Applaus, dann kommt erst mal zweitausend Jahre lang Applaus. Das Problem ist halt, dass sie jetzt gerade irgendwie so einem A-Moll stecken und halt die Kirche nicht benutzen können. Das ist total depressiv. Auch für die nächsten siebenhundert Jahre können wir diese Kirche nicht benutzen, weil halt jemand, weil halt gerade das Stück aufgeführt wird. Scheiße. Das ist schon geil. Das ist schon wirklich geil. Genau wie von John Caincher auch das Stück 4 Minuten 33 ist, was 4 Minuten 33 still ist. Ja. Was auch eine geile Idee ist, weil auch wenn du da hingehst, zur U-Aufführung, zur Premiere, und dann hast du halt ein Orchester aufgebaut. Und dann sitzt das Publikum, setzt sich hin und ist halt alles so feierlich und dann kommt der Dirigent, wird begrüsst, dann das Orchester stimmt und so. Er hat ungefähr eine Stunde lang wieder die Erwartungshaltung aufgeführt, das ist das normalste Stück und es gab noch nie was in der Geschichte, was es gebrochen hat. Und dann wird plötzlich, dann setzt er an, er zählt ja auch an, weil das hat ja auch eine Tempobeschreibung und so, zählt an und dirigiert dann Pausen, vier Minuten dreiunddreißig lang. Ist blöd, aber man kann es ja nicht mehr brechen, das ist ein Gag, den man in einfach hunderttausend Jahren Musikgeschichte, ein Gag, den man machen kann. Das ist einer von vier Gags. Das Element der Pause, das man gibt, macht man zum Beispiel auch Bach irgendwie, dann halt B, A, C, H, seinen eigenen Namen in Noten halt schreiben. Ah, echt? Das hat Schubert, glaube ich, auch gemacht. Schumann. Rachmaninoff hat tatsächlich eine eigene Notation entwickelt. Schubert. Irgendeiner mit Schub. Schubel. Ich glaube Schubert hat aber schon mal kein S. Hatte eine Freundin, die hieß Clara. Und dann hat er ihr ein Stück geschrieben, was irgendwie auch als der beste Stück der Epoche und so gilt. Toll, Schubert, super toll. Die kennen Schubert, toll. Und dann hat er aber einfach nur die Buchstaben aus Clara genommen, die es als Noten gibt, C, A, A. Und alle haben sich gefragt, wow, das hat so viel gebracht, so ein starker Anfang. Und dann irgendwann kam raus, in so einem Manuskript, was er Briefe geschrieben hat, dass er einfach nur die Buchstaben seiner Freundin genommen hat und so random dazugekommen ist. Er ist nicht schlecht. Aber es ist auch der Gag, der ist auch weg. Du kannst ja ganze Bücher dann irgendwie vertonen, wenn du einfach nur die Noten spielst. Auch weg der Gag. Eigentlich sind alle Gags schon gemacht. Da habe ich mir überlegt, ich hätte mal irgendwann gedacht, gibt es eigentlich sehr mathematische Ansätze für Musik und ja, die gibt es auch. Also so Philipp Glas und so hat einfach manchmal auch Algorithmen genommen und dann hat er quasi einfach, dass das C immer nach allen Zehntakten kommt, das A nach jedem neunten Takt und so, dann hat er halt komplett mathematisch ein Stück durchprogrammiert quasi. Auch interessant, kann man auch machen. Es gibt viele Herangehensweisen, es gibt viele neue Sichtwinkel, auch in der Evolution oder in der Musik. Ich bedanke mich. Ich finde, dadurch, dass unsere Aufnahmetechniken immer komplexer werden, dass wir immer mehr Dinge aufnehmen und aufzeichnen können und einfach mehr wissen, was in der Vergangenheit passiert ist, dass sich dadurch irgendwann einfach das kreative Potential erschöpft. Weil einfach früher ist halt alles einfach verloren gegangen und halt die Geschichten vom Nachbarstab waren. Es wurden aber auch viele Gags wiederholt. Kannst du nochmal erzählen. Die können es einfach wiederholen. Du könntest ja, wenn du irgendwo aufknappt hast, oh, da hat jemand in England das langsamste Stück der Welt gespielt und du hast irgendwie eine Freundin in England., ich sag's nicht weiter, sondern ich mach's selbst. Ich mach's selbst, ja. Du konntest auch viel einfach klauen, das fällt jetzt einfach besser, dass du nicht, dass du geistiges Eigentum ein bisschen wertiger ist. Apropos wertig, ich bin jetzt Aktionär. Nein! Herzlichen Glückwunsch! Nee, noch nicht, noch nicht, aber ich habe folgendes mit meinem, ich habe ein bisschen was geerbt und habe jetzt überlegt, das in Aktien zu investieren, weil alle mir gesagt haben… Ist sie auf gar keinen Fall auf Aktien, das ist ein Rule Breaker. Genau, meine Tante habe ich nämlich dann herausgefunden, die kümmert sich um Wertpapieranlagen und guckt halt dann quasi voraus, wann demnächst mal was passieren könnte, wann es einen Börsencrash gibt und so, die eigentlich nur gucken muss, dass auf dem Aktienmarkt kein Scheiss passiert.
Und diese Person hat mir geraten, auf gar keinen Fall in Aktien zu investieren.
Und ich habe es natürlich gemacht, weil ich mir denke, yes, das ist doch geil, anstatt der Markt ist unruhig, wuh, ich stütze mich rein in die Wellen.
Und jetzt habe ich, ich dachte, das wäre echt so ein Filmding, aber der hat mir zu mir gesagt, ja, Sie wollen diesen Wert anlegen, okay, ja gut, dann können wir jetzt alles fix machen, wir legen Ihnen ein Depot an und wenn der Wert gut liegt für uns, dann rühre ich Sie an und Sie müssen mir nur sagen, tun Sie es und dann mache ich das.
und es ist eins zu eins wie im Film und ich freue mich jetzt die ganze Zeit schon auf den Anruf.
Irgendwann kommt dann der Anruf, wollen wir jetzt reingehen und sagen Sie mir einfach die Summe und tun Sie es.
Dann sage ich einfach, alles klar, tun Sie es.
64 Euro. Und ich werde auch nicht, zwei Euro, und ich werde auch nicht mich verabschieden weil das ist glaube ich so ein unspoken rule, du darfst dich nicht verabschieden, einfach tun sie es und dann auflegen und ich hoffe die ganze Zeit, dass dieser Anruf irgendwann in der Redaktionskonferenz passiert oder irgendwo in der U-Bahn, wo viele Leute mir gerade zuhören müssen und ich dann irgendwie dann ich sehe schon kommen, dass ich dann in der U-Bahn bin, der Empfang ist schlecht und so, hallo, sind Sie noch, ja, tun Sie es einfach, nee, tun Sie es, habe ich gesagt. Oder einfach, dass es einfach mega uncool wird, der Moment, oder ich einfach so auf der Strasse bin und niemand hört zu und ich einfach Leute zusammentrommel. Ja, oder dich einfach ganz nah an andere Leute dran stellst, damit ich noch irgendjemand mitbekomme. Und sehr laut spreche, tun Sie es! Verkaufen!
Aber du sagst ihm dann, ob du die verkaufen möchtest. Nee, ich kaufe die auf.
Ich investiere in Aktien.
Du wartest noch auf einen guten Punkt, an dem du sie kaufst.
Genau, an dem der Wert gerade nicht so hoch steht.
Ja, natürlich schwierig. Du weisst ja immer nicht,
ob man nicht noch weiter sinkt.
Das ist halt immer so das Ding. Aber eigentlich soll man noch nicht
darauf spekulieren, sondern sagen, wenn für sich
der Wert gut ist, soll man investieren. Es ist wirklich wie Lotto. Oder wie Roulette. Es ist wie... Oder wie das Leben. Das Leben. Wenn es hoch geht, kann es noch höher gehen oder kann es... Wenn es tief ist, kann es auch noch tiefer werden. Man kann es nicht vorhersagen. Man weiss es einfach nicht. Das ist eigentlich die Krux. Man weiss es nicht. Nimm das aus der Folge mit.
Man weiss nie, wie es weitergeht.
Man weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Es kann in beide Richtungen gehen.
Gleichermassen.
Wollen wir ein Selfie machen?
Und dann?
Einfach mal, machen wir einfach mal einen ganz unironischen Selfie.
Wie ganz normale Menschen.
Einfach, wo wir nett, freundlich in die Kamera gucken.
Ja, es ist kein, oh, guck mal Selfie, sondern einfach, wir beide machen jetzt einfach ein Selfie.
Ja, okay.
Unironisch.
Also wirklich, kriegen wir es hin, auch keine...
Unironisch ein Foto zu machen.
Auch Hashtag Lifestyle, Hashtag Blogger Lifestyle, sondern einfach ein unironisches Selfie.
Ich weiss nicht, ob wir das schaffen.
Und dann vielleicht einfach mal Grüße an unsere Hörer.
Einfach mal unironisch Grüße an unsere Hörer.
Komm, was machen wir mal jetzt?
Aber, okay, aber ist das nicht schon ironisch? Wieso nein? Einfach ein nettes Bild. Einfach wir beide. Ich muss auf die andere Seite. Ja gut, ich sehe aus wie die Opto-Hallose einfach mal. Komm, wahrscheinlich wird das helfen, was wir halt die Seite wechseln. Ich wollte es gerade schon schräg halten, um es zu brechen. Es ist ein Reflex, dass ich nicht einfach ein fucking Selfie machen kann. Warum sehen meine Augen so klein aus? Warum hast du so riesig? Warum sind meine Haare so seltsam aus? Wir lassen das einfach. Nee, warte, du stellst dich ein bisschen ein Stück da hinten, weil du siehst sonst so riesig aus. Nee,rig der Daumen. Der Daumen ist der Daumen. Warte. Ja, einfach so. War ein normales Foto, war nett. War ein ganz normales Foto, hau ich auf Instagram raus. Wie reagieren Leute auf uns, wenn wir unironisch agieren? Das ist, glaube ich, nicht mehr möglich. Aber wir reagieren ja beide auch manchmal unironisch im Privaten. Aber tatsächlich. Du bist ja auch mit Sicherheit nicht auf jeder, aber angenehm man ist auf einer Party, du bist ja nicht immer der beissend ironische Dauer-Gag-Raushauer. Das Problem ist, dass man irgendwann einfach schon so den Ruf hat, dass Leute einen einfach nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Zum Beispiel letztens unser guter Freund, liebe Grüße an der Stelle, Olli P. haben wir ja getroffen, wegen dem Dreh. Und da war tatsächlich das Problem, dass er alles, was ich gesagt habe, dachte, dass ich ironisch meine. So, ey geil, schön dich zu sehen, cool, dass du da bist. Und er einfach nur so, er fick dich. Nee, das weißt du nicht. Das ist einfach ein Problem, weil sobald das mal im Raum steht, kommst du auch nicht mehr raus. Und er sagt, nein, nein, ganz im Ernst, ich freue mich wirklich, dass du da bist. Und es ist sofort wieder ironisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich auch aufhine, aber wenn ich im Autorenbüro mal jemanden lobe und sage, hey Patrick, geiler Text. Ja, aber bei Patrick ist es halt nochmal was anderes. Nein, nein, auch wenn ich sage, Max, mega Gag, dann kommt immer direkt zurück, ja, fick dich einfach. Dann denke ich mir, was, nein. Aber auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir auch, okay, nicht schlecht, dass wir diesen Ruf haben, nur ironisch zu sein, weil kann ja auch heißen, dass man für Gags bekannt ist. Und dass halt man, egal was man macht, man auch abgesichert ist. Also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie komplett betrunken irgendegendeinen Scheiss posten würden auf Twitter oder so, würden die Leute immer sagen, ah, das ist halt ein Gag oder so. Oder wir jemanden einfach im Soft vergewaltigen, die Leute, ja, okay, geiler Gag, so, äh. Genau, obwohl Meta-Ebene, wow. Krass, ey, super krass, cooles Statement, aber man kann sich, glaube ich, eine Menge leisten dadurch. Deswegen finde ich auch immer gut, dass wenn du, deswegen sollte man immer überschätzt werden. Manchmal denkt man auch, okay, geil, Leute wissen nicht, dass ich Klavier spielen kann und so, und dann kannst du dich überzeugen und dann bist du der neue Chopin und haust die Dinge raus. Nein, ich finde, es ist immer besser, überschätzt zu werden. Ja, Overstatement. Weil dann denken alle, egal was du machst, immer, okay, ich kann das nicht ganz nachvollziehen, wahrscheinlich weil ich es nicht fassen kann oder weil ich dem nicht gewachsen bin. Ich spiele anscheinend so gut Klavier, okay, ist anscheinend vielleicht ein Stück von Philipp Gleis, ein bisschen atonal, aber einfach so tun, als wäre man der Kind. Oder er berührt eigentlich die Tassen auch gar nicht, er macht vieles mit seinem Mund eigentlich hauptsächlich, aber okay. Seltsam, aber vielleicht ist das eine neue Kunstform aus Westafrika, weiß ich nicht. Er benutzt die Pedale sehr stark, habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Was ist das, Kupplung, Kupplung, Bremse, Gas? Stark drauf rum, der gute alte Gag, den haben wir auch schon. Ne, das war Otto mit Aquaplaning, ne? Das ist ja auch sein... Ne, das war auch Helge Schneider. Was mir auch gefallen ist, findest du nicht, dass Waterboarding unfassbar geil klingt? Ja, das stimmt. Ich denke mir so, Richtung Sommer jetzt kommen wir. Waterboarding. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Hobby-Waterboarding. Das würde man gar nicht auffallen.
Das klingt total geil. Also ich denke mir so, wow, ich mache Beach-Bolleyball, Wassersurfing. Ja, ich mache Waterboarding. Das ist cool. Ich glaube, 80 von 372 Leuten würden sagen, cool. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine bewusste Art, das zu relativieren als Foltermethode, dass du halt nicht mehr sagst irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Finger abschneiden oder eiserne Jungfrau oder unter Wasser halten, sondern dass man einfach sagt Waterboarding, Wertenböcker Waterboarding, und dann bringst du dich dann nach Guantanamo und dann kannst du mal gucken, was sie sich da eingebrockt haben. Finger abschneiden ist jetzt Fingerprinting, wenn man immer auch. Fingerprinting, ja sowas in der Richtung. Einfach so geile Wörter dafür erfinden, die nach einem lustigen Brettspiel klingen. Das ist ja ganz interessant, einfach die Frage ist, ob Waterboarding wirklich Folter ist oder nicht, dass sie behaupten, wir foltern nicht, unter der Prämisse, dass Waterboarding keine Folter ist. Es ist natürlich auch interessant, einfach dann Dinge als Folter oder nicht festzulegen, wie man will. Das sind ja andere Diskussionen. Womit man einen Trend, wo man so einen Waterboarding für einen gründen oder so? Das ist tatsächlich interessant. Also ich kenne nur, Christopher Hitchens hat sich mal Waterboarden lassen, weil er mal wissen wollte, wie das ist. Und der hatte dann so ein Experiment, der lag dann auf dieser Bank und hatte so einen Schlüssel in der Hand. Man fällt es vielleicht vom Brett runter, es ist ein bisschen schwierig, muss ich jetzt mal an die Balance gewinnen. Stimmt, aber wenn man es mal drauf hat, ist es ganz geil eigentlich. Dann kriegt man einen ganzen Speed und kann ein paar Tricks machen.
Und er hatte so Schlüssel in der Hand, so dieses klassische Einstein-Experiment,
wie du in der letzten Folge sehr...
Das Einstein-Experiment, echt jetzt?
Ja, diese Einstein-Mittagsschlaf-Taktik, dass wenn du einschläfst, dann den Schlüssel
fallen lässt und dich das dann aufweckt. Und das war eben, er lag auf dieser Bank und
hat den Schlüssel in der Hand und habe gesagt, wenn du es nicht mehr aushältst, lass den
Schlüssel los und wir hören sofort auf. Und die haben angefangen und nach wirklich 0,4 Sekunden hat er sofort den Schlüssel fallen gelassen. Was war das denn nochmal? Was ist das denn nochmal genau? Du kriegst du ein, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, Hand und habe gesagt, wenn du es nicht mehr aushältst, lass den Schlüssel los und wir hören sofort auf. Und die haben angefangen und nach wirklich 0,4 Sekunden hat er sofort den Schlüssel feingelassen. Was war das denn nochmal? Was ist das denn nochmal genau? Du kriegst so einen Lappen ans Gesicht und dann gießen die halt Wasser auf diesen Lappen und du liegst halt so ein bisschen schräg, also so ein bisschen nach hinten gelehnt, sodass dir halt das Wasser in Nase und Mund läuft und es fühlt sich halt an, als würdest du ertrinken. Aber du ertrinkst halt nicht, du überlebst halt nicht. Du schwebst in keiner wirklichen Gefahr, aber es fühlt sich halt so an, als würdest du ertrinken. Boah, das finde ich gar nicht unangenehm. Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich extrem unangenehm. Ich finde es auch schon so unangenehm, wenn man rückwärts ins Becken taucht. Ja. Das finde ich auch schon so unangenehm. Apropos Einstein, ich habe neulich das Einstein-Rätsel gelöst. Es gibt dieses berühmte Einstein-Rätsel, wo er irgendwie sagt, der Brite lebt in der Mitte. Und hat einen Hund und trinkt den. Genau, der Däne trinkt Koffee und so. Und dann hast du halt irgendwie so 15 Facts und du musst halt rausfinden, wer besitzt den Fisch. Und der mit dem Fisch wohnt neben dem, der Kaffee trinkt. Genau, immer so weiter. Und das ist schon ganz geil, weil er hat damals behauptet, dass 98% der Menschheit dieses Rätsel nicht lösen können. und ich hab's gelöst. Anscheinend entwickelt sich aber auch so die Menschheit, weil wenn er das behauptet, dann würde ich ihm mal jetzt sagen, Einstein, okay, du hast ein paar gute Sachen gemacht in deinem Leben, dir glaube ich das. Ja. Und jetzt glaube ich mittlerweile, können es mehr als 98%, äh, weniger, äh, mehr als 98% äh, weniger als 98% können es nicht lösen. Ja. Wen Weniger als, aber mehr als, ich würde sagen, ungefähr 98 Prozent können diesen Satz nicht aussprechen. Da gehörst du dann wieder zu den zwei Prozent, die es nicht können. Ganz interessant, ich habe es gelöst. Versuch das auch mal. Ich glaube, ich habe das in der achten Klasse mal irgendwo gelöst. Ja, aber so nebenbei, in der fünf Minuten Pause war ich kurz. Immer ganz kurz, das ist ein Schein-Rätsel. Wir haben eigentlich nur überhaupt, wir haben noch keinen Klassensprecher gewählt, ne? Nee, aber der Sebastian wollte doch ganz gerne Klassensprecher sein. Ich würde gerne mich selbst aufstellen. Oh, das waren so uncoole Leute. Das waren so uncoole Leute. Ich bin verantwortungsbewusst, ich bin immer für die, ich glaube, jeder kann mit mir reden, ich glaube, ich habe eine gute Verbindung zu allen. Du bist ein bisschen dick, du bist Fetty McFat-F Mag sein, aber auch das heißt ja, dass wir in einem gewissen Sitz. Dann sagen alle, oh, die aus LB haben fatty McFatFat zum Klassensprecher gewählt. Gut, aber das zeigt uns ja, zeigt uns als Tolerante. Oder als Wohlgenährte. Als Wohlgenährte, die auch den Winter überleben kann vielleicht, also wenn es hart auf hart kommt. Das ist eine gutbürgerliche Klasse. Warst du mal ein Klassensprecher eigentlich? Ja. Ich auch. In welcher Klasse? In der vierten Klasse. Ja, da kann es auch sein. Die sechsten Klasse. Aber es fällt echt auf, dass die meisten Leute, die hier in der Firma auch Jobs haben, die meisten schon mal Klassensprecher waren. Das ist mir schon mal aufgefallen. Das ist interessant. Ich glaube, es gibt auch wirklich niemanden, der kein Abitur hat. Interessanterweise ist der einzige, der kein Abitur hat, Jan. Hat der kein Abitur? Nee, der hat mittlere Reife, soweit ich weiss. Ich meine, er hat Abitur. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Das ist dann wieder interessant, dass dann sozusagen der Chef als einziger die Ausnahme der Regel ist. Wo wir gerade, unser Chef war auch Klassensprecher, aber sogar Schülersprecher, glaube ich, unser Produzentenchef, und der hat auch mal erzählt, weil ich habe heute ein sehr schwarzes, ein ganz rein schwarzes T-Shirt an. Ist es sehr schwarz oder ist es... Das ist, glaube ich, das schwärzeste Material, was es gibt auf dem Projekt. Man kann, man denkt, guckt man durch mich durch. Und ein Kumpel von mir hat jetzt in eine Startup investiert, die nur weisse T-Shirts produzieren, halt in verschiedenen Formen und so, aber nur weiss. Und ich glaube, der Trend geht auch weg von diesen Beschriftungen, außer jetzt Merch oder so, aber der Trend geht weg von diesen random Aufschriften. Und ich habe auch überlegt, es ist schon ein bisschen seltsam, hier auch so Jack and Jones und diese ganzen Trendmarken, dass die einfach so ganze random Brooklyn 99 und so, so ganz seltsame Aufdrücke haben. Findest du das nicht? Ja, ich... Jacken und T-Shirts und so. Also ich finde das eine interessante Idee, da komplett davon wegzugehen. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wer diese Aufdruckung, der Design, diese random Straßenschilder. Ich glaube, da ist ein ganz ausgeklügeltes System dahinter. Und ich glaube, die Idee ist halt einfach, dass du gerade kein weisses T-Shirt haben willst, sondern dass du halt irgendein mit einer Marke identifiziert werden kannst, obwohl natürlich das weisse T-Shirt an sich auch irgendeine Marke sein kann, gerade halt dann irgendwie so dieses coole Hipster-Gedöst, so von wegen, ich gebe mir keine Mühe, mich anzuziehen, deswegen habe ich nur ein weisses T-Shirt, aber das weisse T-Shirt kostet dann halt 200 Euro oder sowas, weil es halt gerade so aussieht, als wäre es nicht gebrandet und von einem grossen Bruder ausgeliehen oder sowas in der Richtung. Und wie gesagt, unser Chef, der kennt jemanden, irgendwie auch so eine Kunststudentin, die aber nie gut war in Kunst und halt immer so ganz seltsame Zeichnungen gemacht hat. Und die ist jetzt untergekommen bei P&C, und zwar um T-Shirts zu designen. Also stellt sich raus, es ist keine bewusste Entscheidung, es sind einfach nur schlechte Kunststudenten. Die schlechtesten aus jeder Branche gehen in die T-Shirt-Vormachen. Genau, wir brauchen sehr schlechte Studenten. Und dann haben die einfach, und die designen dann einfach die T-Shirts mit wirklich komplett random Motiven, die absolut keinen Sinn ergeben. Denken sich einfach aus, welche Strasse könnte jetzt cool sein in Brooklyn und dann machen wir das und malen wir die Brücke und so. Aber ist das nicht genau die Idee, dass man eben nicht zugeordnet werden kann? Zu konkret, ne? Dass man eben immer möglichst ausserhalb der Norm steht und einfach nicht, ich glaube, das ist der Wunsch von vielen Menschen, einfach nicht in eine Schublade gesteckt werden zu können, dass du einfach sagst, egal was es ist, hauptsache es ist irgendwo individuell, dass du halt nicht sagen kannst, ah, das ist ein Jack and Jones oder so und so, sondern einfach möglichst weird. Ganz seltsam, aber du hast mich immer gefragt, wie das entsteht. Ich bin tatsächlich auch schon so tief im T-Shirt drin, dass ich mir nicht mehr vorstelle, also mir auch... Du steckst sehr tief drin, das sieht man. Dass ich auch von mir selbst nicht es mir leisten könnte, zum Beispiel ich hatte mal eine Phase als Jugendlicher, wo alle cool Hemden tragen wollten, halt cool Hemd, auch so kurzemlige Hemden. Wo alle so cool Hemd, also es ist ein Begriff, das war die Phase, das war die Epoche cool Hemd. Cool-Phase. Und da habe ich mir auch so ein Hemd gekauft, aus so rot, so weinrot, das dann so bis zu den Ellenbogen ging. Und ich habe mich nicht getraut, das anzuziehen, weil es so ungewöhnlich war, dass alle gesagt haben, Gott, was ist denn da los, warum trägst du ein Hemd? Und ich mich dann hätte rechtfertigen müssen. Das heißt, wenn du einfach zu lange... Aber ist es bei dir auch so, ich finde, mein Kleidungsstil früher war immer wie die Evolution. Ich habe etwas so lange getragen, bis irgendwer gesagt hat, das kann man so nicht tragen. Da habe ich es aufgehört. Ja genau, Falsifizierbarkeit, das ist das wichtigste Prinzip. Ich hatte irgendwann mal eine Hose, das sah man, wenn man ganz nah rangeht, hat man gesehen, es war kariert. Es war quasi eine Jeanshose, aber so kariert, so weisse Längsstreifen und so. Und die sah einfach aus, von weitem sah es aus wie eine graue Hose. Und je näher man rankam, es ist ein seltsamer, sah es aus wie so eine Clownshose, um zu flicken. Und ich habe die den ersten Tag angehabt und direkt ging ich auf den Schulhof drauf und dann gesagt, was hast du da an, das kann man nicht anziehen, diese Hose, das ist keine Hose, was ist das? Und ich habe sie nie wieder angezogen. Ich wusste auch noch, dass ich mal eine gebrauchte Jacke gekauft habe, da war ich mit meiner Mutter bei so einem Gebrauchtwaren-Gedöns irgendwie, haben wir uns Kleidung kaufen und dann habe ich so eine Jacke gekauft und tatsächlich habe ich das gar nicht bemerkt, aber die war so ein bisschen länger als eine normale Jacke ist, so ein bisschen so mantelmässig, die blicken so ein bisschen kurz übers Knie. Das hast du nicht gemerkt? Ich habe das gar nicht gemerkt, mir war das auch scheissegal. Und ich bin auf die Schule gekommen und jeder halt sofort, du siehst aus wie ein Mädchen.
Jeder einfach sofort und mir so, ach du scheisse, what the fuck. Das war ein ganz, ganz schlimmer Tag. Na, hause gegangen, nie wieder angezogen, aber das war ein ganz schlimmer Tag und ich habe das auch komplett ins Messer gelaufen einfach. Konnte ich nicht mit rechnen. Aber Kinder sind auch knallhart, ne, einfach, die sagen dir einfach direkt, was du nicht, also ich glaube, du wirst nirgendwo so sehr geprägt wie im Kindergarten, also von der Gesellschaft.
Ja.
Weil die einfach direkt draufhauen, die sagen direkt, das sieht echt scheiße aus, deine blonden Strähnchen, machte die mal wieder raus. Ja. Und dann hast du die aber für ein Jahr. Da braucht man aber auch echt Eier, um da aus der Reihe zu tanzen als Kind, ne? Also das ist schon, ist das nochmal was anderes als heute. Aber es gibt, kennst du Kinder, also aus dem Kindergarten, welche Kinder aus der Reihe tanzen, kennt man kaum. Nee, aber der eine, der halt dann irgendwie meine blonde Strähne trägt oder sowas, der halt dann so viel Selbstbewusstsein hat, der bei mir einfach völlig zu Recht zusammengeschlagen worden wäre, aber dann trotzdem sagt... Aber nicht von dir. Natürlich nicht von mir, von meinen Leuten einfach, ne. Aber ich muss nur zeigen, auf dem Pausenhof. Mit so einer Zigarre, die mir im Mund hat. Ich kann so aufzeigen, und dann kommt die Lehrerin, die Zigarre ist aus dem Mund. Man nimmt keine Dinge von der Straße auf. Und meine Jungs kümmern sich drum. Ich habe viel Kinderkleidung zerstört in meinem Leben. Echt? Von dir selber aber? Nee, in meiner Zivi-Zeit. Da habe ich mit Kindern gearbeitet. Ah, du hast auch Zivi gemacht, ne? Ich habe Zivi mit Kindern gemacht und da gab es ein Mädchen, das hatte immer ganz teure, feine Kleidung an, aber hat halt immer im Dreck gespielt, immer auf so Steinhaufen. Und du hast sie einfach zerrissen. Ich hab dann immer ihre Kleidung zerrissen, weil ich sagte, irgendwie, sonst geht die noch kaputt, irgendwie zieh das mal aus. Du willst mich zerreissen, bevor du es zerreisst. Die hat wirklich fast jeden Tag irgendwas von ihrer Kleidung kaputt gemacht und die Eltern haben irgendwie dann nachgekauft. Und es war echt... Aber hattest du die Wahl zwischen Wehrpflicht und Zivi dann? Ich hab halt verweigert, ja, ja. Du hast verweigert? Ich wurde gemustert. Rausgemustert? Nee, gemustert. Also dass ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie die Klasse geht's gerade noch, so Kanonenfutter oder sowas. Und dann habe ich Kriegssinn verweigert. Und dann habe ich Zivi gemacht. Ah, weil bei mir wurde es ja gerade erst abgeschafft, was ja eigentlich das Beste ist, was dir passieren kann. Ich war doch tatsächlich der letzte Jährige, bevor es abgeschafft wurde, aber es war eine gute Erfahrung, weil ich hätte auch nicht gewusst, was ich sonst hätte machen sollen. Ich hatte mich ja an Schauspielschulen beworben, wurde nicht genommen und dann so, ja okay, scheiße. Das ist auch so eine, was man, was man noch in Talkshows sagen, wie es ganz oft. Wenn ich mal einen Oscar gewonnen habe. Sie haben ja auch bei Schauspielschulen wurden sie abgelehnt. Warum hat es trotzdem noch versucht? Genau, was hat sie trotzdem noch dazu gebracht, weiterzumachen? Bei uns heute, Oscarpreisträger Floridin Will für seinen Film Der Untergang. Ich bin tatsächlich fest davon ausgegangen, dass ich ausgemustert werde, weil ich halt fett war. Und ich dachte, ich habe noch nie fetten Soldaten gesehen. Deswegen gehe ich nicht davon aus. Die werden ja dünn. Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Und dann saß ich dann da drin, auch kurz vor der medizinischen Untersuchung, vor dem alle Angst haben, von wegen musste jemanden an die Hoden packen lassen. Und saß dann da und dachte mir, ach du Scheiße, ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht ausgemustert, fuck, und habe das halt viel zu spät gemerkt und dann ist mir angefangen, dass ich eine Stauballergie habe und dann habe ich versucht, irgendwie auf diese Stauballergie zu pochen und dachte mir, wenn ich jetzt so einen allergischen Anfall habe und ganz viel niesen muss, funktioniert das vielleicht. Dann sass ich in diesem Gang, bevor ich in dieses medizinische Untersuchungszimmer reingegangen bin, und dann habe ich mich wirklich auf den Boden gelegt und habe vom Boden versucht, Staub einzuatmen,
wirklich so auf dem Boden rumzuschnüffelt, versucht, Staub einzuatmen, damit ich auf jeden Fall irgendeine allergische Reaktion bekommen habe. Hat halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Aber ich finde es geil, dass Sie dich dann ausmustern aus psychischen Gründen, weil der jemand auf dem Gang liegt vielleicht. Ja, ja. Oh, nochmal Tipp an alle, die jetzt ausgemustert werden. Am Freitag ist Hitlers Geburtstag. Happy Birthday to you, Happy Birthday to you, Happy Birthday, lieber Adolf, Happy Birthday to you! Und da ist immer ein guter Trick. Hoch soll er leben, hoch soll er leben, dreimal hoch. Gib mir da! Wie schön, dass du geboren bist, wir hätten dich sonst sehr vermisst, wie schön, dass wir beisammen sind, wir gratulieren dir Geburtstagskind. Wir gratulieren dir Geburtstagskind. Und da ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute Strategie, dass wenn ihr am Freitag euren
Musterungstermin habt, dass ihr einfach schön in die Musterung reingeht und einfach sagt,
hier alles Gute zum Führer geboren. Und da ist es auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute Strategie, dass wenn ihr am Freitag euren
Musterungstermin habt, dass ihr einfach schön in die Musterung reingeht und einfach sagt, hier alles Gute zum Führergeburtstag, dann seid ihr sofort raus. Echt? Das sind also die beiden Strategien, halt Nazi oder schwul kannst du immer machen. Schwul? Warum bist du denn ausgeboten, wenn du schwul bist? Ja, weil du jetzt zusammengeschlagen wirst in der Truppe oder so. Auf gar keinen Fall! Keine Ahnung. Ist das ein Grund? Also das wäre ja höchst skandalös. Nee, also Es ist natürlich vieles Klischee behaftet, aber ich glaube, dass es da bestimmt in der Bundeswehr Leute gibt, die sagen, wir wollen keine Schwulen in der Truppe haben. Meinst du nicht? Ich kann mich an Diskussionen erinnern, dass es immer hieß, wenn du auf die Psychoschiene machst, dann machst du einfach psychisch labil oder Nazi oder schwul. Okay. Und dann ist halt die Frage, was dir am ehesten liegt. Das ist auch eine Persönlichkeitsfrage so ein bisschen, was du am ehesten machst. Ich habe jetzt Apocalypse Now zum ersten Mal gesehen und ich entdecke so die Dinge, wie gesagt, die vor 15 Jahren mal interessant waren. Ich war auch da schon ziemlich alt eigentlich. Ja, in der Tat. Und habe jetzt dann die Doku geguckt von ... Ah ja, Heart of Darkness. von Sophia Coppola. Ne, Elena, von der Frau von Francis Ford Coppola. Stimmt, aber Sophia Coppola sieht man manchmal, ne? Ja, die war sie noch ganz klein, er kommentiert manchmal so ein bisschen. Also die Doku über die Dreharbeiten von Apocalypse Now. Die Dreharbeiten zu Apocalypse Now war wirklich, das war wirklich ein Apocalypse, einfach. Die Dreharbeiten waren total krass, die mussten sich dann, weil er um Bürgerkrieg spielte und so, Da mussten sich dann, die haben sich wirklich die Hubschrauber geliehen von der Armee, von der philippinischen Armee, die hier gerade dann war. Wurde auch gar nicht alles in Vietnam geraten, sondern in den Philippinen, mega interessant. Und die wollten irgendwann auch ihre Hubschrauber zurück, weil sie kämpfen mussten, ne, über die Wärme drehen. Das heißt, die mussten aneinander die Hubschrauber abziehen, mussten dann unten ein paar Bürgerkriegsstandorte zerstören und sind dann wieder zurückgekommen mit den blutverschmierten Helikoptern gehen. Das ist ganz interessant.
Auch weil die es so ein bisschen erklären, dass die halt in dem Film zum ersten Mal darstellen wollten, wie Soldaten den Krieg damals wirklich wahrgenommen haben, den Witten am Krieg. Weil da war halt gerade so diese Hippie-Rock'n'Roll-Zeit und so.
Und dann haben die halt damals einfach da die ganze Zeit, waren die auf LSD und haben halt wirklich da die ganze Zeit Stones gehört und Rock'n'Roll gehört und haben einfach eine geile Zeit gehabt. Da gibt es diese Szene, wo die Stones hören und die Erkennung Satisfaction im Hintergrund, Surge ist ja einer von denen, quasi in diesem Patrouillenboot, was einfach auch, die meinten, natürlich eine geile Szene, auf der anderen Seite war es der erste Abbild zum Krieg. Ganz interessant. Ja, Krieg ist Fun, glaube ich, ist ja auch die Grundaussage des Films. Also ich habe wirklich überlegt, wie ich diesen Krieg wahrgenommen habe, hätte ich da echt mal Bock drauf, das für eine Woche zu erleben. Ist dir schon klar, dass sie den Krieg verloren haben, dass das nicht so gut lief für Amerika letztlich? Ja, gut, gut. Aber ich finde es immer interessant, also auch wie Kriege innerhalb künstler Zeit komplett anders geführt werden. Also auch allein durch die Einführung des Hubschraubers plötzlich einfach eine komplett andere Art von Kriegsführung stattfindet. Dass sie plötzlich Truppen einfach aus dem Nichts absetzen können, da kämpfen und sofort wieder abziehen können. Ist tatsächlich sehr krass. Auch Flugzeugträger ist glaube ich so ein riesen Ding gewesen einfach, dass du irgendwann landen konntest, ohne irgendwie Flughäfen von benachbarten Ländern oder so. Du könntest ja einen transportablen Flughafen zu haben. Das ist eine geniale Idee eigentlich. Ja, aber das war tatsächlich auch ein Problem, weil die haben ja oft, also die Amerikaner, auch die Punkte, an denen sie landen wollten, mit den Hubschraubern halt vorher mit Artilleriebeschuss beschossen, wodurch die Vietnamesen halt immer relativ genau wussten, wo die Amerikaner ankommen. Und dadurch, dass sie ja diese Tunnel- und Höhlensysteme hatten, konnten die halt immer nur dann kämpfen, wenn sie auch kämpfen wollten. Das heißt, wenn sie einfach gerade irgendwie nicht bereit waren, haben die sie einfach versteckt und dann sind die Amerikaner ins Leer gelaufen und sind wieder abgezogen. Und immer wenn sie halt bereit waren zu kämpfen, haben sie gekämpft und haben gewonnen. Das heißt, sie hatten immer die Gelegenheit, immer gut einfach Kämpfe zu führen und konnten so halt irgendwie dann auch letztlich die Amerikaner einfach schlagen. Ganz ganz seltsamer Krieg, ne? Die Taktik halt immer ausgenutzt haben, einfach immer nur dann zu kämpfen, wenn man sich relativ sicher sein kann, dass man gewinnt. Echt nur wieder der Krieg. Die konnten halt auch nie irgendwie Land gewinnen, weil die Amerikaner halt immer Land genommen haben, alle abgeschlachtet und groß gewonnen, sind dann halt wieder abgeflogen und die Vietnamesen haben das einfach wieder eingenommen letztlich, weil sie halt einfach nie irgendwie gute Positionen einnehmen können. Weil sich halt niemand da so gut auskennt. Ja, und von Krokodilen gefressen wurden tatsächlich. Genau, ist auch krass einfach, wie gibt es diese Folge von Bear Grylls, wie er durch Vietnam läuft, dann und das ist schon krass einfach, weil er einfach erklärt dann, okay, es ist einfach wahnsinnig gefährlich hier, die Wasser, es ist Flut und dann haben sich die Amerikaner meistens an Flüssen orientiert, weil du halt halbwegs überleben kannst, wenn du gerade, wenn du trennt wurdest von deinen Truppen, aber dann kommt er manchmal die Flut und du semst dich einfach um und dann hast du auch verloren. Das ist ein militärischer Begriff, um Sensen. Um Sensen. Ja. Was ist dein Lieblingskrieg? Sensen. Die Schlacht um Sems? Das Sems kommt zurück. Mein Lieblingskrieg ist, glaube ich, der Zweite Weltkrieg, glaube ich. Bei mir war es der Erste, glaube ich. Also da befasse ich mich gerade intensiv damit. Zu intensiv. Vielleicht zu intensiv. Wie deine Mutter mir gesagt hat. Ja, ich habe mein Bayonetta auch dabei. Sie hat mich angerufen, weil sie sich zu sehr damit beschäftigt. Ja. Ist ja unangenehm. Und dein Nachbarn ist auch schon aufgefallen. Die haben sich dann bei ihr gemeldet wiederum. Lustige Geschichte. Aber kleiden wir vielleicht nach dem Podcast. Vielleicht mal mit so einem Veteran aus dem Vietnamkrieg mal reden. Ah, die sind glaube ich unangenehm. Meinst du? Ja, ja. Die sind sehr patriotisch vielleicht. Verklärt, vieles verklärt. Ja, das sind diese verkl es sind so unangenehmen Rollstuhlgesichter. Ohne Beine. Rollstuhlgesichter. Wenn ich hier so einen Rolli-Typ mir reinvollne. Rollstuhlgesichter sind ein schönes Wort, weil es ergibt keinen Sinn, man weiss aber genau, was du meinst. Ja, es ergibt echt absolut keinen Sinn, aber man sieht es doch ein bisschen. Ja, man hat was vor sich. Sorry, wenn wir gerade irgendwen beleidigen, aber auf der anderen Seite, wir haben doch jeden schon mal beleidigt. Ap Aber wo beleidigen, wen wir auf gar keinen Fall beleidigen wollen, sind natürlich unsere treuen Zuhörer, die uns immer gerne unterstützen auf Patreon zum Beispiel und uns da nett unterstützen. Und natürlich haben wir auch die Verpflichtung, eine Gegenleistung zu erbringen. Und zwar wollen wir immer die Leute vorlesen, die tatsächlich sich das Recht erkauft haben, in dieser Folge erwähnt zu werden. Und Stefan? Erstmal vielen Dank, wir haben 110 Euro pro Monat mittlerweile eingenommen. Das heisst, wir brauchen eigentlich nur noch ein bisschen, um mal ein paar gute Gäste einzuladen zu können. Um lustiger zu werden. Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen, um aus unserem, also ich sag mal so, so 500 Euro pro Monat wären schon ein ganz geiler Anreiz, um aus dieser Krise rauszukommen, in der wir erst denken. Kommen wir jetzt zu unserer neuen Rubrik, dem Patreon-Nachrichtendienst. Wir brauchen Geld, wir brauchen Geld, gebt uns ganz viel Geld und fangt an zu rauchen und Drogen zu nehmen. Auf patreon.com könnt ihr uns unterstützen mit einer kleinen finanziellen Spende und wenn ihr fünf oder mehr Dollar spendet, dann könnt ihr euch das Recht erkaufen, eine kleine Nachricht in diesem Podcast abzusenden. Erstmal schon mal vielen Dank an die vielen Leute, die das schon gemacht haben. Nicht alle haben auch in Anspruch genommen, auch jetzt Nachrichten zu schicken. Wir haben nur drei Nachrichten bekommen. Danke für euer vieles Geld. Danke für euer Geld. Und gebt doch bitte noch mehr. Wenn ihr noch mehr Geld gebt, werden wir lustiger. Martin Fabisch hat geschrieben. Fabisch! Fabbisch! Hör auf, für jeden Mist Geld Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld Christian sagt, hey, Podcast-Sufo-Team, wie ihr sicher schon gemerkt habt, bin ich ein echter Seitfolge-Elfhörer und daher ist mir das 5 Dollar pro Monat wert. Das ist nett. Ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, in dieser Nachricht einen Text zu schreiben, bei dem der Zuhörer beim Vorlesen nicht unterscheiden kann, ob das noch die Nachricht ist oder ob euer Gespräch noch weitergeht, aber das hätte wohl keiner verstanden. Ist aber keine schlechte Idee, aber ich glaube, das haben wir letzte Folge schon vorgelegt.
Wir haben so Elan losgemacht.
Im Gegensatz zu jetzt.
Ich wollte es heute ein bisschen feierlicher machen.
Danke für die tolle Nachricht, Christian.
Du bist ein super Typ und Melanie sollte sich noch mal über dir überlegen.
Da hat er recht. Ist auch meine Meinung, aber da müsste
er mit Stefan reden. Das ist ein intimes Thema.
Und Dani Glasgow schreibt
super, das weiß ich aber nicht, ob es eine private Nachricht ist oder ob er bei uns fünf Euro gespendet hat. Wir lesen die trotzdem mal vor. Wir lesen die zur Hälfte vor. Super Podcast. Wir lesen die ganz vor. Am bittigsten finde ich Herm. Sehr gut. Dankeschön. Wie gesagt, wenn ihr noch fünf Euro gespendet habt und eure Nachricht jetzt nicht wiedergefunden habt, dann schreibt uns bitte auf, noch mal auf einem anderen Weg, kontaktiert uns. Ich weiß nicht genau, ich kriege die Mails auch nicht, vielleicht hast du noch welche bekommen, meldet euch. Wir kriegen das schon hin, aber es ist ja immer so, man diskutiert ja immer sehr viel und ich habe schon viele Diskussionen geführt über Podcasten und so von wegen, weil in Amerika läuft es mega gut, da verdienen viele Leute viel Geld damit, können davon leben und in Deutschland ist alles so ein bisschen scheiße. Aber würden wir irgendwas ändern, wenn wir davon leben könnten? Ich glaube nicht, wir wollen nicht davon leben, wir wollen einfach irgendwie neuen Scheiss kaufen und irgendwie Sachen dumm schwarzen kaufen. Aber angenommen, wir würden davon leben können, also angenommen, es wäre wirklich einfach unser Job-Podcast-Uko. Wie cool wäre das denn? Wäre schon ganz cool, aber dann hast du immer wieder das Argument, ja die Zuschauer machen dich fertig, wenn du Geld bekommst, weil dann alle denken,, ne, ne. Und tatsächlich habe ich immer gesagt, nein, wenn die Leute Fans sind, wenn die dich cool finden, wenn die irgendwie Bock auf das Projekt haben, dann nehmen die das nicht böse. Aber es kam tatsächlich diese Woche ein Kommentar, der finde ich diese gesamte Problematik mit Geldeinnehmen für Dinge, die irgendwie umsonst waren und für die anderen kam tatsächlich und irgendwie, es geht mir nur um Föbelierung, irgendwie jetzt, wo ihr Geld verlangt. Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Absolut Quatsch, wir verlangen kein Geld. Ich möchte einfach dieses Wort, in welchem Universum denkt dieser Mensch, dass er hier das Wort verlangt benutzt? Das ist ja schon, also völlig egal, was danach kommt. Du kannst aber auch sein, dass du das in die Gagfalle trappst. Aber das ist mir egal, das ist mir wirklich egal, unsere Kommentare sind einfach sowieso komplett vor die Hunde gegangen, weil du einfach nicht mehr zwischen Ironien unterscheiden kannst. Und das ist tatsächlich ein Punkt, der mich nervt, weil ich einfach die Kommentare nicht mehr lesen kann und da einfach keine Information mehr rüberkommt, weil Ironie einfach so nicht funktioniert. Und einfach das Wort verlangt. Das finde ich gerade ein bisschen schwarz-weiss. Ganz kurz. Das muss schon klar sein. Nee, aber schau mal. Verlangt ist auf jeden Fall. Verlangt istlangt ist komplett ver... Und es ist auch die Prämisse, wenn du... Egal, was danach kommt, ist komplett egal. Weil die Prämisse falsch ist. Wir verlangen kein Geld. Und auch, ich weiß noch nicht, warum er sich die Realität so anders vorlügt, dass er sich beschweren kann. Das ist genauso wie dieses Argument mit dem Tweet damals. Hättest du was anders getweetet, hätte ich mich aufgeregt. So dieses, man belügt sich selbst nur, damit man sich aufregen kann, die verlangen ja jetzt Geld. Nein, ist einfach falsch. Aber ganz schön, die Kommentare finde ich ganz interessant, weil Ironie funktioniert so nicht. Ironie ist ein Stilmittel, das verstanden werden möchte. Ironie ist einfach nur ein rhetorisches Stilmittel, zielt aber auf ein Verständnis ab. Genau, wenn das Ziel Unverständnis ist, ist das Ironie als falsche Mittel oder einfach falsch angewendet. Wenn man als Kommentar schreibt, oh die Folge war ja richtig scheiße und man meint das ironisch, es gibt keine Möglichkeit für uns rauszufinden, ob das ironisch gemeint ist oder nicht. Es ist auch keine Ironie. Die Idee von Ironie ist ja auch ein Schlüssel mitzuschicken. Genau, ein Kontext zum Beispiel, wenn wir sagen. Der Schlüssel kann Kontext sein, kann eine Person sein. Du schickst einen Schlüssel mit, der dir hilft, das zu dechiffrieren. Genau, wenn wir sagen, Podcast-Ufo, der beschissenste Podcast der Welt, weisst ihr, das ist ironisch, weil es unser eigener Podcast ist. Aber du kannst nicht Herr der Ringe schreiben und dann ganz am Ende sagen, okay, das war alles ironisch gemeint oder das war alles nur ein Comedy-Buch zu verstehen. Nein. Aber deswegen sind Kommentare einfach ein Problem, weil sie keinen Kontext haben und weil man einfach als Rezipient keine Möglichkeit hat, es zu entschlüsseln. Man weiss einfach nicht, wie es gemeint ist. Schreibst du manchmal Kommentare oder schreibst du manchmal, du bist in Foren aktiv, ne? Ich schreibe auch manchmal Kommentare, aber da bin ich tatsächlich extrem humor, also schon ein paar Gags, aber wirklich, ich versuche mich so klar, wie es geht, auszudrücken, weil ich die Problematik einfach kenne, dass so ab einem gewissen Punkt und je ironischer wir sind, desto ironischer wollen ja auch die Zuhörer sein. Was ja auch okay ist, aber schickt uns einen Schlüssel mit, hilft uns es zu dechifrieren. Aber Ironie ist halt auch eine Sprache, die man sprechen können muss und einfach nur zu schreiben, oh was für eine Scheisse und dann zu denken, haha, wir finden das lustig oder nicht, führt letztlich dazu, dass die Kommunikation komplett zusammenbricht und man einfach nicht mehr kommunizieren kann. Was der Fall ist, so ein bisschen leider, aber das kriegen wir wieder in den Griff. Ja, vielleicht. Ein paar ernste Worte zum Schluss. Man muss vielleicht ein paar ernste Worte sehen, aber vielleicht basiert es auf ein paar Missverständnissen, die man vielleicht aus der Welt schaffen kann. Gern. Ich bin dafür, Dinge aus der Welt zu schaffen. Auch wenn sie gut sind. Einfach mal Dinge aus der Welt. Hier wird es langsam so ein bisschen voll auf unserem kleinen blauen Planeten. Damit einfach ein paar neue Dinge entstehen können, muss einfach mal ein bisschen was raus. Ich bin auch nicht gegen Bücherverbrennung per se. Ich sag einfach mal. Es kommt drauf an, welche Bücher. Lass uns einfach mal 80% aller Bücher verbrennen. Glaub, die letztlich, ich glaube, die letztlich, oder da der...
Das war ein Gen, einfach nur.
Reaktion, Gen.
Ich glaube, es ist der Effekt, der dadurch entzielt wird, ist besser als der Verlust, den wir dadurch haben.
Aber mal weg damit!
Weg damit!
Ich muss ein bisschen Hör aussprechen!
Hörbe!
Igel!
Also, ich wünsche euch viel Spaß da draußen, genießt die Sonne ein bisschen, legt euch mal raus. Ich wünsche euch einen schönen Sommer, geht mal raus da, geht mal an Badesee oder an die frische Luft zumindest. Oder die Eisdiele, man, schön Bananasplitz sich einfach mal auf die Kiemen legen. Oder ein Spaghetti-Eis oder einfach mal echt Spaghetti-Essen im Eisrestaurant. Das wäre geil, das wäre mega lustig. Einfach mal so, alle sagen, wow, das Spaghetti-Eis sieht aber authentisch aus. Nee, ist ein echte Spaghetti.
Leute lachen sich kaputt.
Gut.
Okay, wir hätten vor zehn Minuten Schluss machen sollen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß, geniesst die Sonne und geht mal raus und empfiehlt uns mal ein paar gute Podcasts.
Das waren Florentin und Stefan.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao, wie bausi!